اليوم تعال شوف القائمة في مراكز الحجامة
تعالج الجيوب الأنفية والصداع والشلل النصفي
والإيدز والسرطان والبرستاتا وضعف مش عارف إيه
قائمة مخيفة
شوف بقول لك حاجتين، ماني مصدقك، وأن أمي بتكرهك
أن إيه؟
أمي تكرهك من الحين، هي ما تعرف الحلقة بس بتكرهك
مثل الثعلبة ويجي يقولك حط ثوم
صحيح
طيب إذا ضبطت وأنا ما راحت المستشفى
أيش تسمي هذا يا أستاذ يا فاهم؟
صحيح، مين اللي يقول ثوم؟
ترى اللي يقول الثوم الطب الشعبي برضه
إيه، بس أنه يشتغل
لا، ما يشتغل
ليش؟ ليش أنت قلت لا بهذا الحدّية؟
لأن ما فيه ، هو ما فيه
الثوم فيه مواد، أيش هي أنا ما أدري
خلاص، أيش تسوي
هي فيه مواد أكيد الثوم
الثوم ممتاز مع البروستد فقط
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
الحين بدأ الشتاء، ومع الشتاء يجي الزنجبيل والعسل
اللي يعالج نصف الأمراض
طبعًا ضيفي في هذه الحلقة يضحك
مو يضحك، لا يقهقه إذا سمع هذه السواليف
فهو عنده تصنيفين للعلوم
فيه علوم حقيقية، وفيه علوم كاذبة
العلوم الحقيقية بالنسبة له منها العلم الطبي الحديث
والعلوم الكاذبة منها الطاقة، الطب الشعبي
الطب الصيني، الطب الهندي، أي شيء
صحيح أن الطب الحديث استطاع زيادة متوسط عمر الإنسان
إلى الضعف تقريبًا، إلا أن هذا لا يعني بالضرورة
أن الطب الشعبي أو القديم أو البديل هو طب غلط
وما بين هذه وهذه نقاش طويل
ومعلومات ثرية وحديث ماتع مع ضيفي «همام عقيل»
أستاذ المناعة والعدوى، استشاري مختبرات إكلينكية
قبل أن نبدأ
فيه بودكاست أحبه، البودكاست هذا أطلقناه في ثمانية
قبل كم أسبوع، يقدمه «محمد آل جابر» و«هادي فقيهي»
بودكاست اسمه «جادي»
كل أسبوع يناقشون مواضيع اقتصادية واجتماعية
مثل ليش الأسعار تترتفع أو تنخفض
أو أثر التخفيضات أو البطاقات الائتمانية على طريقة استهلاكنا
وغيرها من المواضيع الاقتصادية
اللي تمسنا مباشرة في حياتنا الشخصية
يتناقشون حولها ويعرضون فيها
سياق جديد للأحداث والظواهر الاجتماعية
النقاش فيه ماتع ومختلف، ونقاش لا يشبه إلا «محمد» و«هادي»
حلقة جديدة تنتظركم كل أربعاء، رابط الاشتراك في وصف الحلقة
وشكرًا لراعي الحلقة شركة «صفا» ومنصة «سلة»
أما الآن لنبدأ
بنزهقك عاد
لا هو، ماشاء الله، واضح أنه مطّلع
واضح أنه فاهم يعني أيش أبحاث علمية
فكان النقاش، بس هو متبني وجهة نظر
تحتاج تفاصيل أكثر عشان تقدر تتبناها بالقوة هذه
وعاجبني الحماس هذا
طبعًا الحين السمعة اللي زي الزفت حقتي عارف
إيه سمعتك
إيه والله زي الزفت عارف
هذا ضد أي شيء شعبي، مو كذا
بس أنت ضد أي شيء شعبي، صح؟
لا مو صحيح، شوف أنا ضد حاجة اسمها العلوم الكاذبة
كل الناس ضد العلوم الكاذبة
إيه، بس أنت ما تعرف أنها علوم كاذبة، هذه الفكرة
كيف تعرف أنها علوم كاذبة؟ أيش هي العلوم الكاذبة؟
اليوم تعريف المصطلحات يفرق كثير
اليوم تتكلم لي الطب البديل
حتى الطب الحديث أنا فيه أشياء ضدها، لأنها علوم كاذبة
عطني أيش فيه شيء ضد الطب الحديث ضده أنت
مثل أيش؟
موجود. أقول لك القهوة لازم أشربها؟ وللا عادي نحط الكوب بس؟
ليه أنت ما تشربها؟
لا، أنا بعد 12:00 الظهر ما أشرب قهوة
«ديكاف»؟ عادي حطها، إعلان
إيه ما في مشكلة، تبغاني امدحها؟ امدحها
امدحها قول هذه قهوة
لأن «خطوة جمل» أنا في بيتي، في مكتبي
في عيادتي، في كل مكان؛ موجودة
شباب طلعوني أحلى من الواقع فضلًا
الواقع سيء
أحلى من الاثنين
وأبغاكم تساعدوني في شيء، مو أنت، أنت لا تساعدني
أنتوا تساعدوني في شغلة
الموضوع ترى مرة راكب فوق بعض، كلاكيع، ومعقد ودخلاته كثير
أنتم الآن مشاهدين، لو حسيت أن فيه شيء
قد أكون ما وفقت في شرحه بشكل كافي
أنا ممكن أعيده بطريقة ثانية
أنا بحاول أخليها بأبسط لغة ممكنة
تبغى ينبرش وسط الحلقة؟
عادي أنا ما عندي مشكلة
أنا انكسر عندي حاجز الكاميرات هذه
و«روتانا» كسرت عندي حاجز البث المباشر
فما عندي صرت أهتم صراحة
أيش كنت تقول بالطب الحديث؟ لأن أنا ماني مصدقك
أول شيء، بقولك حاجتين
ماني مصدقك، وأن أمي بتكرهك
أن إيه؟
أمي تكرهك من الحين، هي ما تعرف الحلقة؛ بس بتكرهك
والله شوف أنا بقول حاجة لو انفهمت بشكلها الكامل
وانشرحت بطريقتها الكاملة؛ بالعكس أمك بتكون أول من يحبني
وأول من تحب حلقتك
يمكن في نص الحلقة بتقول لك عبدالرحمن اعمل له حظر
في النص الثاني، بتقولك لا أجيبه البيت عندنا نعشيه
فهذا اللي بيحصل
بتعشيك بابونج وأعشاب
مو مشكلة، بس ما تكون ادعاء علاج
لا، أجل هي أيش تتوقع؟
هي، ما شاء الله لا إله إلا الله، تسوي أشياء كثيرة
تحب السواليف هذه، الطب الشعبي
والله؟
إيه
شوف كلهم، كل الأمهات كل الأمهات، الخالات، الأعمات، الجدات
وأحيانًا اللي تستغرب منه حتى الجيل الجديد عنده
فهذه صحوة علمية
يا ساتر يا رب، أنتم في غيابة الجّب
والله لو تفهموا واقع الأمور وتفاصيلها وحقيقتها
أنت بتنصدم حتى من أشياء بعيدة عن المجال الطبي وبعيدة عن علاجه
بتشوف أن فعلًا فيه شيء لازم نتبه له
أيش مشكلتك مع الطب الشعبي؟
أنا ما عندي مشكلة مع الطب الشعبي
أنا عندي مشكلة مع العلوم الكاذبة
العلوم الكاذبة خطيرة لأن...
عرّف العلوم الكاذبة
هي أي ممارسة تدّعي أنها علم
ولما تشوفها من بعيد كذا؛ تقول والله علم
بس هي ليس لها علاقة بالعلم
عرّف العلم
طيب، العلم هي ممارسة قائمة على أساسات
الأساسات هذه وضعت لتجنب الوقوع في العلوم الكاذبة
وخليني أقول لك على شغلة
فيه مصطلحات لعلي أسس لها من الآن
على أساس أن نتكلم كلنا بنفس اللغة
اليوم لما نتكلم في جلستنا نقول نظريتي، فرضيتي
أنا افترض كذا، نظريتي والله في الموضوع كذا
يُفهم المعنى العام حقها أنها رأيي
في العلم اللغة مختلفة
في العلم عندك حقيقة، فرضية، نظرية، وقانون
أيش الفرق بينهم؟
الحقيقة للعلم هي أول شيء تشوفه
اليوم الحقيقة في العلم هي أني طالعت من الشباك
لقيت الدنيا فيها نور، في النهار الدنيا فيها نور؛ هذه الحقيقة
محاولتي لتفسيرها الحقيقة، سأضع عدة فرضيات
أيش الفرضيات هذه؟
مثلًا أن فيه نجم اسم الشمس طالع وهو اللي معطي النور
لا، شركة الكهرباء مدت أسلاك على طول الرياض
وحطت لمبات، هذه هي اللمبات
لا، القمر انفجر وهذا نوره
كلها فرضيات
وهنا النقطة المهمة، أنا أحاول أثبت أو أتحدى الفرضيات هذه
فرضية فرضية بمحاولة نقضها
أنا أجمّع بأدواتي اللي أملكها اليوم
أحاول الفرضية اللي أنا وضعتها أني أنقضها مو أثبتها
لما أفشل في نقضها؛ صارت هنا نظرية وهي أقوى أشكال العلم
لما أحاول أجمع الأدلة حولها؛ هذا علم كاذب
هذا إنحياز، هذا لا يعد علمًا إطلاقًا
القانون هو طريقة أو معادلة حسابية ثابتة تتغير
مثلًا خلينا عشان نكون أوضح
الجاذبية فيه قانون، أنت في الأرض، على القمر
في المريخ؛ تقدر تحسب الجاذبية
اليوم أنا ماسك كرة، رميتها طاحت في الأرض
أنا أقدر أحسب كم سرعة نزولها واحتكاكها بالهواء
أقدر أطلع لك بالمللي بمعادلة رياضية
بس هذه ما تفسر لك أيش الجاذبية، تحسب لك الجاذبية
اللي يفسر لك الجاذبية هي النظرية العلمية
عشان كذا اليوم عندنا «نيوتن» هو اللي عرف القانون حق الجاذبية
بس «انشتاين» هو اللي عرف نظرية الجاذبية
فهذه اللغة، لما أقول لك النظرية العلمية لا تعني رأيي العلمي
لا، ما هي مثل كلامنا
معناته أقصى الدرجات اللي وصل لها العلم
في تفسير هذه الظاهرة وتوقع ما يرتبط فيها من ظواهر أخرى؛ هي هذه
ممتاز، إذا كذا بنتفق على أن الحقيقة بالنسبة لك
تختلف عن الحقيقة بالنسبة لي؟
بالنسبة للعلم، بالنسبة للغة العلم
الحقيقة هي ما تشاهده وتلاحظه
بس أنت تقدر تشوف شيء وأنا أشوف شيء ثاني
لا يعني أن أنت ما تشوف الحقيقة وأنا أشوف الحقيقة
صحيح، عشان كذا هي أضعف الأشكال
هي أول شيء، هي الملاحظة
أنت تضع الفرضيات وتحاول تفسرها، هذا أيش؟
ممتاز. هذا على الشكل النظري
بس على شكل الحياة، احنا ما نتقاطع كثير مع هذه الأشياء
وأتوقع مشاكلك ما تتقاطع مع الفكرة هذه، وللا؟
فتاخذ العلاج اللي ممكن يطلع اليوم صح
وبكرة يطلع غلط، وهو تكوّن أنه علاج
تاخذ العمليات وللا فكرة الطب الحديث
اللي جالس يتغير كل شوي ويثبت أنه كان خطأ وصار صح
واللي صار اليوم؛ بيصير بكرة غلط
أتفق نسبيًّا، مو بشكل كامل
أول شيء، العلوم الكاذبة ماهي داخلة بس في العلاجات
داخلة في كل شيء يا عبد الرحمن
أنت اليوم لو تعرف العلوم الكاذبة
هي أصلًا أساس البلاء في كل شيء
دقيقة، نقدر نقول علم الطاقة علم كاذب؟
طبعًا
فعلم الطاقة كاذب، لأن جالس يبيّن أنه علم بس ما في شيء يثبته وللا؟
هو لو تلاحظ وتقرأ؛ بتلاقي فيه أدلة
خليني أقول لك على شغلة
أيش اللي يخليني أفرّق ما بين هذا علم حقيقي وللا علم كاذب؟
ما أعرف
أول نقطة، حاجة يسموها القدرة على تكذيبها
أنا اليوم أجي أقول لك، الاستوديو حقكم وراء الجدار فيه سحابة
السحابة هذه هي اللي تساعد أن جو الغرفة يكون معتدل
تجي تقول لي أنا ما قد سمعت
ما في شيء في العلم يقول أن السحاب يجي بين الجدران
فبقول لك لا موجودة، بس أنت ما تشوفها لأنها بين طبقات الأسمنت
بتقول لي لا، تعال نبغى نكسر الجدار، أبغى أشوف السحابة هذه
بقول لك لا، لو كسرت الجدار؛ الأسمنت بيتفاعل
أنت الآن كلما تعطيني شيء بالعلم الحقيقي أو بالأشياء المثبتة
تبغى تثبت فيها أو تحاول أن تنقض فيها هذا الادعاء
اللي أنا بقوله؛ بحط لك فيه معوقات
ومنت قادر تكذب على الفكرة حقتك
نفس الكلام، مثل ما تفضلت علم الطاقة
علم الطاقة اللي يجي يقول لك
هو أصلًا عنده مغص في بطنه
لأن فيه طاقة سلبية متجمعة حول الصُرّة عنده، تعال أنا بسحبها له
تقول له الطاقة كلها تقاس، هذه أنت كيف قاعد تقيسها؟
يقول لك لا أنا بس أقيسها، أنت ما تقدر تقيسها
طيب أنت كيف بتقيسها؟ لا أنا علمني «ريكي ماستر»
طيب «ريكي ماستر» كيف تعلموها؟ كذا بتدخل...
يا رجل ليش نروح بعيد، الأرض مسطحة
تجي تناقشه يا ابن الحلال عندنا الأرض كروية
يقولك لا، هي مسطحة
طيب تعال أنا أقولك، الكسوف، الخسوف، النجوم، الشفق، مواقعها
كل ما أشرحها له؛ لا، علم الجيولوجيا حقكم ذا علم أصلًا كاذب
الفلك هذا علم يضحكوا عليكم فيه
السماء عبارة عن شاشة عرض
الأرض عبارة عن دائرة وحولها فيه ثلج ومقفلين
طيب تعال أنا أستأجر لك على حسابي هليكوبتر
وروح لطرف الأرض هذا، نبي شوف الثلج هذا
لا أنت ما تقدر، لأن هناك «ناسا» واقفة لك بالأسلحة
هذا اللي تسمعه، هذه الرؤية
إذا أنا ما أقدر أكذب ادعائك، هذا يجعله من أضعف أشكال هذا
وهذا يجعله علم كاذب
أيضًا عندك اللي كنت أقولك عليه في العلم
أنه يحاول الإثبات بنقض
بغرض النقض
لما أفشل في النقض؛ هنا يقف هو ويقول
في الناحية الثانية لا، بتلاقي هو يجمّع الأدلة
يشوف الدليل اللي يمشي مع كلامه ويحقق هذا؛ يحطه
والعلوم الكاذبة بعضها يناقض أساسيات العلم
وتلاقي فيه تجارب وأبحاث منشورة، بس هو علم كاذب في النهاية
اليوم إذا سمعت عن العلاج بالهوميوباثي
شوف حتى اللي نشّز في بريطانيا
يوم جات فترة دعمته ماليًّا و بعدين وقفت الدعم حقه
هو طريقة علاج تدّعي، اليوم لدغك ثعبان مثلًا
أنا أعالجك بتخفيف سم الثعبان، هذا بيكون علاجك
المعنى عندهم أن كل ما خففت الشيء اللي يسبب السمّية أو المشكلة
وأخذته؛ هذا هو علاجك
فالكلام أصلًا يناقض، بل ما له علاقة في الطب
يناقض العلوم اللي في رابعة ابتدائي
يناقض جميع أشكال العلوم اللي في الحياة
أي مادة ما يزيد تركيزها مع التخفيف
ما في مادة يزيد تركيزها مع التخفيف، هذا أساس
فأنت لما تتكلم على الأشياء هذه
يقول لك واحد، يا أخي العلم فيه أشياء ما يعرفها اليوم
ما عندي مشكلة
لما تجيني، فيه مقولة يقولك
جيب لي دليل بقوة ادعاءك؛ العلم مستعد يطالع فيه
أما غير كذا...
فيه مثلًا لما تقول الأرض مسطحة
سهل جدًّا أن تقول خلاص نطلع في الطيارة
طبعًا فيه يمكن تطلع في الطيارة، ليش الأرض ما تجي
بس الموضوع ثاني
إيه على أساس أن تأتي
لكن يمديك تمشي في الطيارة، وتمشي معاه وأنها طبيعية وتقدر تقيسها
تقدر تشوف برأي العين، وتكتشف أن لا ماهي مسطحة
بس الطاقة، ما تعتقد أن إنسان فيه روح و الروح غير قابلة للقياس
العلم ما يستطيع معرفة الروح، ما يعرف أيش هي
فيه في الدين، بس في العلم ما يعرف
إذا نبغى نطلعها من الدين، اللي هي الوعي
ما يعرف أيش هو الوعي
من أنت؟ أنا ما أقدر أعرف أيش اللي يشكّل همام، ما أعرف
لو قطعتك وحطيت قلبك، رأسك، عقلك، لو بدلته؛ بتبقى أنت أنت
بس متى يتغيّر همام ما ندري
ففيه الوعي اللي احنا ما نعرفه
فنقدر ناخذ على شكل من أشكال الأشياء
اللي احنا ما نعرفها في هذه الحياة
اللي الطاقة هنا ياخذ دور، يمكن ما يقدر يثبت
بس ما يمديك تنفي عدم وجود هذه الروح الموجودة
وأن الأرواح لها طاقة
خلنا نتفق على شغلة، أول حاجة اليوم لما تقوم بادعاء
أنت اللي عليك أن تثبته مو الطرف الثاني اللي لازم ينفيه
اليوم لو أجي وأقول لك أثبت لي أن ما عندك بيت
كيف بتثبتها؟
أنا بطلّع لك «توكلنا»
ما تقدر تثبت لو ما عندك بيت
أنا علي أثبت أن أنا مدّعي أن عندك بيت
أنا علي أثبت أن عندك بيت، صح؟
صح
نفس الفكرة، أنت اليوم تدّعي أن الشيء هذا موجود
وأنت قادر على علاجه، وشايف أشياء ما أحد شايفها
ومنت قادر تثبتها، وتبغاني أنا! ما أقدر مستحيل، أنت عليك تثبتها
وبعدين ترى على فكرة الأرض مسطحة والطيارة
حتى هذه عندهم رد عليها
لا، الحد هذاك اللي أنت شايفه هذه انكسار بلورات الموية
فأنت تشوفها مائلة بس هي مائلة، ما تخلص
تقول الأرض مسطحة، الأرض الكروية؛ في النهاية ما بتؤثر علينا
احنا لو نجي ناخذها في ناحية الأشياء اللي ممكن تؤثر علينا، تضرنا
وللأسف دخلت حتى في العلاجات
دخلت في الأشياء هذه كلها
الخطر هنا
هو أصلًا أيش اللي يخلي العلوم الكاذبة تزدهر؟
أيش اللي تخلي الناس تحبها؟
شوف الإنسان بشكل عام عنده رغبة أن يتحكم بمصيره
أو يعرف مصيره، ويقرأ المستقبل حقه، ويعرف هو ماشي فين
وما يحب الغموض في القادم
الأبراج مثلًا، أنت بيصير كذا، بتتزوجي وللا لا
وأنت في تاريخ كذا بيصير لك كذا، وبتترقى في كذا
أو انتبه من الأشخاص اللي كذا
هذا وهم وأدّى لمشاكل في بيوت، أدى لمشاكل في أعمال
وحتى الغرور حق الشخص أنه ما يقدر يفقد الفكرة
اللي هو متعلق فيها بسهولة
أنت تقول له تعال حبيبي، هذولا اثنين توأم
ولدوا في نفس اليوم وفي نفس اللحظة، تعال شوف
كل واحد شخصيته شيء، وكل واحد في مكان وظيفي معين
مختلفين تمامًا
هو شاف الدليل قدامه بس صعب يتركها
فهذه أحد الرغبات
الرغبة الثانية، الميل للبساطة
اليوم لما تجي تقول لي أنا مريض سكر
أيش مرض السكر هذا؟ وأجي أقول لك حبيبي مرض السكر
عبارة عن جهاز المناعة بيهاجم خلايا البنكرياس
وبيخليها ما تفرز إنسولين كافي اللي يخلي الخلايا
أيش التعقيد هذا اللي أنت مدخلني هو
ويجيك واحد ثاني، يقول لك تدري مرض السكر
هو عشان أنت كنت تاكل شوكولاتة كثير وحلاوة كثيرة وأنت صغير
خلصني، وهذه الخلطة هي تنظف لك الأشياء القديمة اللي عندك
وأنت خلاص لا علاج ولا شيء، اخصرك من الدكاترة
شفت ميلنا للبساطة يخلينا نميل باتجاه هذا
فيه ناس ما يقدروا يطلعوا من المشكلة حق العلوم الكاذبة
لأن في حاجة اسمها تصعيد الالتزام
فاكر الفترة اللي جات هبة البرمجة اللغوية العصبية؟
إيه فاكرها هذه
واحد دفع ثلاثة أو أربعة آلاف ريال وحضر دورة
وبعدين دخلوه في دورة متخصصة ثانية بثلاثة أو أربعة آلاف
بعدين راح اشترى أحجار كريمة من مدري مين تبيعها
عشان هي تسوي لك مدري أيش في الطاقة
دخل في التزام ودفع فلوس؛ ما يبغى يحس أن ترى انضحك عليك
ولا فيه أي فايدة وكلام فاضي
فيقعد متمسك في هذه النقطة
الانحياز
الانحياز التوكيدي
الانحياز التوكيدي وانحياز التصديق، الاثنين
انحياز التصديق أيش هو؟ تكراره
اليوم لما تسمع كورونا هذا مشروع يبغوا يخففوا فيه سكان العالم
كورونا يبغوا يقللوا فيه سكان العالم
لما تسمعه يتكرر ويتكرر
تجي تقول، لا يكون فعلًا فيه مؤامرة يبغوا يخففوا عدد العالم
هذا الانحياز حق التصديق هذه مشكلة
والانحياز التأكيدي مثل ما تفضلت
الانحياز التأكيدي اللي هو أنا أجمّع الأدلة
أحط هذا على هذا وأقول...
اللي تأكد فكرتي اللي أنا أبيها
اليوم أنا وأنت وللا أنت وأيمن تجي تقول
أيش أحسن دولة سياحية في أوربا؟
أنت تقول له هولندا، وهو يقول لك إيطاليا، ليش؟
طيب، يلا كل واحد يعطيني هذا
أنت عشان تبي تثبت هذا؛ بتجمّع الأدلة ليش هولندا أحسن
بس ما بتناقش مثلًا غلاء الأسعار، القيمة المضافة، درجة الأمان
قد لا تبحث عنها أصلًا، لأن أنت تحاول...
نفس الفكرة، أندرويد وآيفون
نفس الأشياء، تحاول تجمع الأدلة اللي تثبت وجهة نظرك
ولكن ما بيكون عندك التفكير النقدي التحليلي
اللي تاخذ خطوة لوراء وتنظر
منطقي أن أغلب الناس ما عندهم هذه القدرة، صح؟
هي مهارة تتطور مع الوقت، هو لازم تكون عندك
حتى بمستوى معين، لازم تطورها عندك
لأن الضحية في الكلام هذا مو بس عموم الناس
حتى المختصين في أي مجال، في هندسة، في طب، في أي مجال
يمكن أن يكونوا ضحية ويبنوا عليها أشياء ويثبتوا فشلها مستقبلًا
التفكير الناقد مهم بطريقة كبيرة مع الفهم النظري الأساسي
مع الفهم التجريبي؛ هذه كلها مع بعض تصنع لك الفارق
وترى أدمغتنا ممكن تخدعنا
كلما زاد ذكائك، كلما قدرت تخدع نفسك
إيه، لأن أصلًا اللي بياخذ القرار هو عقلك، وعقلك من فين؟
أيش البيانات اللي بنت خلال حياتك؟
من حواسك انبنت البيانات، من التربية
من الضغوطات النفسية والحياة الاجتماعية
هذا اللي بنى عندك القدرة اليوم أن تاخذ قرار
أو خلى عندك قرار معين تجاه قضية معينة
اليوم أنت لما تتكلم...
الأدلة الخذالة لما أقولك فيه دراسات مثبتة، أو دراسات موجودة منشورة
هو الدراسات موجود فيها أدلة
بس هنا نرجع لنقطة الانحياز التأكيدي
اليوم لما نجي نتكلم، علاج الجلطة تلاقي واحد جاي بالكوي
جاء لسّع هنا في أكثر من مكان
فيه حالة طبية اسمها «تي آي إيه» اللي هي الجلطة عابرة
تجي جلطة تمسك وتطلّع أعراض وتعدّي
أنت لما تروح لحق الكي هذا كواك في أكثر من مكان
وفعلًا الجلطة راحت. أنا عندي دليل هي الجلطة راحت
بينما هذا مو دليل هذا يسموه ضجيج
خلينا نسميه خراء مو دليل حقيقي
لأن سبب روحة الجلطة هي طبيعة المرض نفسه، وليس اللي سويته
نفس الشيء، فيه أمراض تجيك تطلع وتنزل
النوبات أو الدورات حقتها
عندك السخونة، الملاريا. السخونة، الانتكاسات اللي فيها تطلع وتنزل
نفس الشيء التصلب المتعدد
هذه نفس الشيء هي تطلع وتنزل
فأنت لما تاخذ حاجة في فترة النزول، أنت تعتقد أن هو السبب
بينما ماهو السبب
اليوم ما تسمع الناس اللي تقولك...
هذه هنا نرجع للنقطة حق أمي وأمك وخالتي وخالتك
لما يكون عندك التهاب في حاجة مثل كذا
وتروح المستشفى وهو التهاب بكتيري، وتحتاج تاخذ مضاد حيوي
وتاخذ المضاد الحيوي، المضاد الحيوي هو يساعد المناعة
فتبدأ آثاره وخفة الأعراض بعد 48 ساعة مما تبدأ تاخذ العلاج
فأنت أول يوم بتاخذ المضاد الحيوي؛ ما في أي تغيّر
أمك ثاني يوم تحن عليك وللا صاحبك
يقول لك يا عم خذ الليمون بالنعناع، وحدة بوحدة وزنجبيل
أنت تاخذه وفعلًا تنام وتصحى أنت طيب
صح
بتصدق أن هذا دليل، هذا اللي عالجني
فأنت أعطيت بطاقة خاطئة
أو الناس الي عندهم سرطان راح...
والله مساكين زملائنا في تخصص علم البيئة
جلسات كيميائية، علاجات، أدوية، متابعة، تحاليل، أشعة
سوّى كل شيء معاه
لما يروح بعدين، واحد من أصحابه يعطي له خلطة
يعطي له شيء، وللا عصير بصل وللا أيًّ كان
خذ هذه ويشربها؛ ويقول لك والله شوف...
طيب الكيماوي هذا أيش صار عليه؟
العلاجات هذه أيش صار عليها؟
فيعطي الفضل ينسبه لهذه الأشياء، ما ينسبه للحقيقة
خلني برجعك شوي وراء، وأقول لك أن أنت تقول فيه العلوم كاذبة
هل أنت بتسقطها على الطب الشعبي أنه علم كاذب؟
شوف العلوم الكاذبة في الطب الشعبي والطب الحديث موجودة
فممكن يكون فيه طب شعبي صحيح؟
لأن أنت بغرض أنه يطلع كذب
مثل الثعلبة ويجي يقول لك حط ثوم
صحيح
طيب إذا ضبطت وأنا ما رحت المستشفى
أيش تسمي هذا يا أستاذ يا فاهم؟
إ]ه صحيح، هي الفكرة مو على كذا
الفكرة أصلًا مو علم كاذب، مين اللي يقول ثوم؟
ترى اللي يقول ثوم الطب الشعبي برضه
إيه، بس أنه يشتغل
لا، ما يشتغل
خليني أقول لك على حاجة، أنا أعطيتك
أيش هي الثعلبة؟
ما أعرف، اللي أعرف أنها كثير تصير للرجال
الثعلبة مرض مناعي، الجسم يهاجم بصيلات الشعر
المناعة تهاجم بصيلات الشعر وما تطلع
أيش علاقة الثوم في المناعة؟
يعطي مناعة؟ مدري أنا
شفت! نفس النقطة
أنا أقول لك على حاجة عشان أقرب لك المثال أكثر
فاكر الظاهر قبل سنة أو سنتين، أنا خلاص كبرت معادني مثل زمان
فيه واحد قبضوا عليه، كان برضه يعالج بالكي والأشياء ذي كلها
المحزن في ذيك الأيام الفيديوهات اللي كانت منتشرة
الطابور كأنه «البيك»
فكان اللي يزعّل أن ناس كثيرة راحت له
يعالج الناس اللي أحد أطرافهم ما يتحرك أو ما تشتغل
بسبب الجلطات أو كذا يعالجها بالكي
لما أنا أسمع ادعاء مثل كذا
تعال نتكلم على الأساس، أيش هي الجلطة؟
خليني أبدأها من كيف تحرك يدك أصلًا
عشان ناخذ مثال، يد يمين
اليد اليمين هذه عشان تتحرك
الفص الأيسر من الدماغ عندك بيرسل إشارات
وتروح للحبل الشوكي وتنزل على أعصاب اليد
بتحرك العضلات الهيكلية الإرادية وترفع يدك
لما يكون عندك مشكلة جلطة أو مشكلة حصلت في الفص الأيسر
بتلاقي الحركة هذه تأثرت
لو قعدت من اليوم إلى بكرة إلى السنة الجاية
تكوي لي في اليد، تحرق اليد، تسوي عمليات، تحط علاجات
ما لها علاقة، المشكلة مو من هنا، المشكلة من هنا
أنت اليوم عندك النت في الشركة هنا في فنجان
النت مفصول من شركة اتصالات
لو غيّرت ألف مودم ما اشتغل النت
نفس الفكرة، فأنت كون أنك تدّعي أن هذا يعالج
هو أصلًا منطقيًّا ما له علاقة في المشكلة، أنت مشكلتك هنا
مهما تعالج هنا وتكوي هنا، ما بيحل المشكلة
نفس الكلام تقول لي الثوم والثعلبة
لو كويته واشتغلت؟
ما تشتغل
طيب لو اشتغلت؟
ما تشتغل، هذه هي الفكرة
هو يكوي في الرأس؟
لو كويت الرأس؟
ما يشتغل، أنت في المخ
مو معقوله كل الناس تروح، وما اشتغل ولا مرة؟!
أنا هذا اللي بقول لك عليه، لو كان مثل اللي قلت لك عليه «آي تي إيه»
أن هي الجلطة عابرة، دخلت وفكّت
وجيت وانكويت وطلع واشتغل كل شيء
هذا ما له علاقة في أن الكوي هو اللي ساعدك
أصلًا لو ما سويت شيء؛ هي بتعبر وتروح تشتغل
هل الثعلبة ممكن تطيب لوحدها؟
طبعًا، حتى الكريمات هذه
لأن أعرف ناس فعلًا ما راحوا مستشفى وحط ثوم ورجع
لو ما حط ثوم بتلاقي نفس النتيجة، هذه هي الفكرة
يمكن إيه، بس أنا أقول لك حط ثوم ونجح
عاد ضبط، كذب ومو كذا؛ رجع شعره
ليش؟ عشان كذا أنا أقول لك احنا نحاول
أنا عشان أثبت أن الثوم يعالج لازم أحاول انقض الفرضية هذه
فنقضها سهل، لأن الثوم أصلًا ما له علاقة بطبيعة المرض
ما له علاقة بسبب المرض، ما له تأثير على المرض
لو نشرح المناعة يا عبدالرحمن
مو الثوم، الثوم واللي يقول لك خذ هذا يرفع المناعة
وكل هذه الأشياء بتقعد أنت لما تسمع بعد كذا الادعاءات ذي تقعد تضحك
بنجي للمناعة، بس هل الثعلبة مرض جلدي؟
أطباء الجلد هم اللي يعالجوه بس هو مرض مناعي، سببه مناعي
فلا يمكن علاجه من هنا؟
إلا ممكن علاجه من هنا
هل ممكن أنت تحط الثوم، لأن فيه مواد في الثوم؛ الجسم يتفاعل معها؟
لا
ليش لا، ليش قلت لا بهذه الحدّية؟
لأن ما فيه، هو ما فيه
الثوم فيه مواد، أيش هي أنا ما أدري
خلاص أيش تسويه
هو فيه مواد أكيد الثوم فيه
الثوم ممتاز مع البروستد فقط
ما ينفع لأي شيء ثاني
طيب حتى لما يجي يقول لك كثّر ثوم في الشاورما
إذا أنت شاك أنها بتجيب لك تسمم
التسمم اللي في الشاورما من بكتيريا اسمها «سالمونيلا»
ولا الثوم يقتلها
بالله عليك؟
إيه والله
عشان كذا أنا أقول لك فيه أشياء غير منطقية أصلًا
ما لها علاقة بطبيعة المرض
أن الأشياء هذه، سواءً الزنجبيل، أو البرتقال، أو أي حاجة
الزر، كل اللي يمشي في الطب الشعبي
ممكن فيه مواد تساعد المناعة أو تساعد شيء من جسمك
أن يبدأ يتعامل معها؛ فتؤدي غرض ما يخليك تشفى
أنا عشان شايف الموضوع رايح في اتجاهين
الاتجاه الأول، خلي المناعة على قولك لما نجيها؛ نشرح هذه النقطة
لكن خليني أرجع أأكد لك
الطب الحديث يستخدم الأعشاب للعلاج، ما عنده عيب
اليوم أدوية الكحة اللي في الصيدلية كلها من الأعشاب «اللبلاب»
ما في مشكلة، أيش اللي فَرق؟
أيش اللي فرق؟
اللي فَرق أني أخذت العشبة هذه ودخلتها في البحث العلمي
أخذت الخطوات الصحيحة للبحث العلمي
اللي تخلينا ما نقع في العلوم الكاذبة
ولما ثبت نجاحه؛ أنا استخرجت المادة وأعطيتك إياها، هذا علاج نعم
فيه أشياء ثانية تكون مفيدة
بس مخلوطة في نفس النبتة أو العشبة؛ فيها مواد سامة
لا، أنا أطلّع. ولما أطلّع أنا أعرف الجرعة، الكمية
قد أيش يضرك، كم ممكن ينفعك، وبعطيك هذا هو
فهو مصدر العلاج من فين؛ عمره ما هو مشكلة
لأن أنت لو تعرف طريقة الطب الحديث
أو العلم الحقيقي في عمل الأبحاث؛ بتفهم ليش صعب جدًّا
هي أفضل طريقة اليوم وصلها البشر
لعدم الوقوع في خطأ أو استنتاج خاطئ
هي وضعت عشان لا نقع في استنتاج خاطئ
ما وضعت عشان تعقّد الناس
فلما أنت تجي تبغى تختصر لي إياها، وللا ما تبي تمشي عليها
وتدّعي الادعاء هذا، والادعاء ممكن يقتل، ممكن يضر
وهذا ثابت طبعًا
احنا الأحداث اللي قدامنا موجودة ثابتة، ممكن يقتل، ممكن يضر
حتى لو الادعاء هذا...
أنا ليش أقول لك أن العلوم الكاذبة خطيرة
لأنها تلبس عباءة العلم
فيه أشياء من الطب الحديث ثبت جزء منها
يقوم العلم الكاذب ياخذه، وهو يزوّد عليه الأشياء حقه
ويقول لك هذا علم، هذا مثبت
لا، هذاك المثبت الجزء هذا، وليس كل شيء
مثالها، العلاج بالخلايا الجذعية
اليوم نعم ثبت علميًّا بشكل كبير أنه يعالج بعض أمراض سرطنات الدم
بس تعال شوف أيش الادعاءات اللي موجودة
الادعاءات: خشونة الركبة، ومدري أيش في الظهر
في الكلى الفشل الكلوي، في العين ضعف النظر
هذه سببت كوارث، فيه ناس ماتت
فيه ناس جاهم أورام في العمود الفقري
ما في حاجة ثبتت، اللي فائدتها بالعكس ثبت ضررها
عشان كذا ما تقدر تقفز على خطوات البحث العلمي وتتجاوز بعضها
والله ضبط في سرطان الدم؛ بتضبط في كل شيء، لا
أنت اليوم عندك ادعاء لأي حاجة، لازم تمشي في الخطوات وحدة وحدة
خطوات البحث العلمي مثل ما قلنا احنا
هي فرضية وتحاول تثبتها وتحاول تنقضها
وأنت أصلًا لازم تكون عارف
التجربة العلمية تبدأ من مختبر البحث
بدينا في المختبر، ثبتت في المختبر بالطريقة العلمية هذه
الآن نوحّد الطريقة أنها طريقة علمية، ثبتت في المختبر
الخطوة القادمة بتبدأ تشغيل على حيوانات التجارب
للتجارب في فئران، جرذان إلى الشامبانزي، هذه بتمشي فيها
نجحت على حيوانات التجارب
بعدها تبدأ تروح إلى المراحل الإكلينكية اللي هي على الإنسان
وهنا تفصيل، مرحلة أولى، مرحلة ثانية، مرحلة ثالثة
وكل مرحلة لها حيثياتها
وعدد محدد من الناس، ما يبدأ تجربة عامة
مو هي تبدأ بعدد صغيرة عشان تختبر الأمان
بعدين عدد ثاني عشان تختبر النجاعة، بعدين تفتحها
وشوف هنا لازم تبدأ تحط حساب العمر، الجنس، العِرق، العِرق يفرق
استجابتك للعِرق يفرق
تفاصيل كثيرة
الجدير بالذكر أن ليس كل تجربة تنجح في المختبر
بالضرورة تنجح على الحيوان
وليس كل تجربة تنجح على الحيوان؛ ممكن تنجح على الإنسان
وليس كل تجربة على الإنسان؛ تنجح مع جميع الناس
عشان كذا البحث العلمي الرصين له خطوات يخليك أنت فاهم
عشان كذا اليوم لما أحد يسوي لك عملية بيقولك...
الطبيب لما يتكلم معك يقول
شوف هو بيعطيك ممكن 80% يساعدك 70%
العملية تنجح بنسبة 40%
هو عارف بيتكلم عن أيش، هو عارف لأن فيه أساس مستند عليه
أنا أعطيك نقطة، إذا تسمع عن «البلاسيبو»
«البلاسيبو» هي أعلى درجات أو آخر مرحلة في البحث العلمي
«البلاسيبو» هو الوهم
أول شيء خلينا نؤصل «البلاسيبو» و«النوسيبو» لأنها مرة مهمة
لأن هذه خادعة حتى في العلوم الكاذبة
أبدأ لك بالـ«النوسيبو» وهو كيف أن الوهم ممكن فعلًا يسبب لك ضرر
اليوم، من 30% - 35% من الناس لو مؤمنين
بسبب انحياز في إيمان، في تصديق، في فكرة معينة
أن الشيء هذا بيضرهم ولو تعرضوا له بيضرهم
يختبروها في الأدوية، أساسية
أعطيك حبوب على أساس أنها دواء، هي طبعًا ما فيها مادة فعالة
سكر وللا ملح وللا موية، ما فيها أي مادة فاعلة
وأقول لك أن من الأعراض الجانبية حقها
أنها ممكن تسبب لك غثيان واستفراغ، ممكن دوخة
من 30% - 35% بيصابوا، بالرغم من أن ما فيها مادة فعالة أصلًا
نفس الكلام، فيه شخص خارج السعودية
صار لخبطة في عيناتهم في فحص ما، إلى آخره
واحد من الأشخاص عنده سرطان مرحلة آخيرة
فأرسلوا النتيجة حقته بالغلط لشخص ثاني
ووصلت لشخص ثاني، راح تعيش أسبوعين أو ثلاثة، فترة بسيطة
لما اكتشفوا الخطأ، وراحوا بيحاولوا يوصلو له؛ لقوه فعلًا مات
وهو ما فيه شيء
ما فيه شيء
ترى هذا الكلام اللي أقوله أنا مثبت ومنشور وموثق
بينما الناحية الثانية «البلاسيبو»
اليوم عشان الـ«إف دي إيه» يفسح دواء أو علاج معين
لازم أخليك توصل لمرحلة أن أنا اليوم مثلًا عندي علاج ضغط
عندي 100 شخص متطوعين للتجربة
بجيب الـ 100 شخص، أنا عندي 100 حبة
الـ 100 هذه نفس الشكل بالضبط
ولكن خمسين منها العلاج بالمادة الفعالة
وخمسين منها لا يوجد شيء «بلاسيبو»
بعطيها للأشخاص هذولي
البيانات اللي بتطلع، هل فعلًا نزل الضغط عندهم
طبعًا أنا متحكم بأعمارهم، بحالة الضغط
فيه لها المعايير حقتها
لو فعلًا نزل؛ كمان العلم أعطاك شيء إضافي
عشان التأثير النفسي حق «البلاسيبو» هذا
ضعف العمى، مو بس معمية أن أنا ما أعرف
لا، حتى الشخص اللي هو العالم اللي يسوي التجربة هذه ما يعرف
جاته 100 حبة مخلوطة مع بعض ما يعرف أيش العلاج، ويعطيه
شفت هذه الخطوات؛ هي اللي تخليك اليوم لما يطلع شيء عندي
نعم أنا واثق أنه عدّى
فيه «بلاسيبو» بالجراحة على فكرة كمان
كيف؟
فيه شيء اسمه جراحة زائفة
الجراحة الزائفة أوهمك أني سويت لك عملية جراحية وأنا ما سويتها
نعم أدخلك كغرفة عمليات وتمريض وأخدّرك
وأجي أفتح وأخيّط، بس ولا سويت شيء
هذه فضحت ادعاءات علاجية كثير، في عمليات جراحية ما لها قيمة
مثل؟
جات فترة حق عملية تنظيف الركبة
يدخلوا يغسلوا الركبة بالمنظار ويغسلوا الركبة
وتتسوى في المستشفيات عندنا
هذا ما لها فائدة، الجراحة الزائفة فضحتها
جابوا مجموعة أشخاص ناس وهم ما يعرفوا، عندهم مشكلة في الركبتين
فتحوا الركبتين، واحد خيطوا له ما يعرف أنه ما سوى شيء
والثاني غسّلوا له؛ نفس النتيجة
واو!
نفس الشيء صار على موضوع اللي هو
أنا ما أعرف، هم تخصص العظام هم أفهم مني
ولكن فيه حاجة مثل المادة الأسمنتية يحطوها بين الفقرات
للناس اللي عندهم تآكل؛ نفس الكلام
سووا عملية وفتحوا وقفلوا؛ نفس النتيجة اللي طلعت هنا طلعت هنا
اللي سوّى العملية واللي ما سوّى العملية
اللي فتح وقفل، واللي حط الأسمنتات؛ نفس النتيجة ما في فرق
هي قديمة في الخمسينيات، إذا ماني واهم، أو الستينيات 1950-1960
وشوف هذا لما أقول لك المختص ممكن يقع فيها
الآن احنا عندنا فهم كويس اليوم للقلب
وكيف يتغذى وكيف احتشاء القلب
فاهميناها من سنوات طويلة
في حالة من الحالات، الشرايين اللي تغذي القلب فيها انسدادات
فيكون فيه ضعف تغذية لعضلات القلب
الشرايين هذه أصلًا جاية من شرايين في المنطقة اللي فوق
جنب الأكتاف وتنزل على تحت
جزء منها يدخل على القلب ويغذيه
وجزء منها يكمل على تحت
فجاء الجراح قال احنا في الوقت الحالي
نحتاج أكبر ضغط للدم وأكبر كمية من الدم
عشان تغذي القلب أهم شيء عندي، عشان يعيش
فأنا اليوم أبغى الشريان هذا اللي نازل خليه داخل القلب
بعد ما يدخل القلب، أبغى أقص واخلي الضغط كامل يجي للقلب
علميًّا، فيه منطق علمي، مبني على أساس علمي
على فهم تشريحي، على وظائف أعضاء، واضح
قالوا له، بس أنت ما عندك تجارب، قال نبدأ نجرّب
وفعلًا، دخلوا المتطوعين، وسووا العملية وفتحوا
وسووا قص لهذا وقفلوا، ممتاز المريض تعالج
وسووها مرة وثانية وثالثة وعشرة؛ نجاحات فائقة في العملية
الين جاء شخص قال يا جماعة دقيقة، اللي أنتم قاعدين تسووه هذا
هذا الدليل اللي أنتوا طلعتوه من العملية
دليل انحياز تأكيدي
احنا نبغى دليل أقوى
أما يثبت هذا الموضوع ويخليه حقيقة نشتغل عليها ويكملها ونطور عليها
أو أن ننقضها
أنتم عشان عارفين من نفسكم أننا بنسوي كذا في القلب بالفهم النظري
أن هذا بيصير كذا، والفهم أنه بيغذي القلب أفضل
فأنتم النتيجة هذه استنتجتوها قبل ما تحاولوا تنقضوها
وبالفعل جاوا وسووا جراحة زائفة، هذه على مرضى من نفس النوع
نفس النتيجة، اللي فتحه وخيّطه نفس النتيجة
أيش اللي يضحك في الدراسة
اللي سووا لهم جراحة زائفة نتائجهم كانت أحسن كمان
فمن يومها طبعًا تم إيقاف العمليات هذه وما عاد مورست من جديد
عشان كذا دائمًا الأدلة وتقييمها تحتاج إلى تفكير ناقد
أنت اليوم عندك هذولا عندهم أساس علمي انطلقوا منه
وعندهم أساس تجريبي انطلقوا منه، نتائج تجريبية
لكن التفكير الناقد هو اللي مكّنهم أن يعرفوا أنهم خطأ
بس يا أستاذ همام، يا حبيبي أنا عندي مشكلة معك
مشاكل كثير مو مشكلة واحدة
مشكلتي الحين هنا هي أنك تسمي هذا علم حقيقي وهذا علم كاذب
الكاذب واضح أنك تحط فكرة أنه يدري أن فيه شيء
بس أني جالس يكذب عليك وأقولك شيء ثاني
لا، مو هذا القصد. فيه ناس من اللي بيمارسوا العلوم الكاذبة
هم مؤمنين فيها، ليس في ظنهم أنهم يكذبوا على الناس
تضليل الناس
لا، أنا ما ادّعيت كذا
أنا أقول هو العلم بطبعه كاذب لأنه عكس الحقيقي
لا يمثّل المعايير حق العلم الحقيقي
بس هذا علم حديث
أيش هو هذا؟
العلم الحديث اللي أنت تقوله، حديث حتى نسبيًّا كم؟ 150 سنة
فاحنا نتكلم عن شيء جديد
وفي العلم الحديث اللي أنت تشوفه حقيقي
فيه كثير من الأخطاء أو من الأشياء الغريبة اللي كانت تصير
سواءً أن «الكوكايين» كان علاج، «الهيروين» كان علاج الزكام
أيش اسمها حق الفص الأمامي
اللي يدخّل فيه مثل المسمار في عينك عشان الاكتئاب
ما لحقت عليها
هذه 1970 الظاهر انتهت
يشيل الاكتئاب ويدخّل مسمار في عينك هنا
وما أدري أيش يبغى يشيل حاجة وراء
يعني مليان خرابيط حتى هو
ويقدر ياخذ الأدوات، والأدوات هذه جديدة احنا اللي اخترعناها
صحيح
والعلم الشعبي والعلم القديم، سواءً الإسلامي وللا العربي
وللا الصيني وللا الهندي؛ له آلاف السنين ويشتغل
فليش هذاك صار كخة الحين؟
هي ماهي كخة، خليني أبدأ أول شيء نؤصل لحاجة مهمة
اللي تتكلم عليه الطب الحديث، أيش مزاياه؟
أيش اللي خلاه علم حقيقي وعلم حديث وطب حديث؟
هو أول شيء ماشي على أساس علمي
ماشي بالخطوات العلمية اللي اتفقنا عليها
أيش يدرس الطب الحديث؟
الطب الحديث يدرس وظائف الأعضاء
وبعد ما يدرس وظائف الأعضاء، يدرس معها المرض
ويدرس مسببات المرض وسلوكها
ويقوم بالتشخيص لعلاج سبب المرض
الممارسات اللي أنت قلتها هذه صحيحة
بس أيش الأدوات اللي مكنته في ذاك الوقت
أن يعرف عن جسم الإنسان أكثر؟
اللي يدرس وظائف الأعضاء أكثر، يدرس الأمراض أكثر
اليوم احنا التقنيات في التحاليل والأشعات؛ هذه فتحت أبواب
التقنيات اللي في علم الوراثة وعلم الأحياء الجزيئية؛ فتحت أبواب
هذا لما تمكّن؛ هو التحسن
هو العلم مو ثابت، العلم يتحسن إلى اليوم
ولا عنده مشكلة في كذا
ما عنده مشكلة اليوم أن الممارسة اللي أنا بمارسها
ممكن تكون غلط أو فيها جزء من الخطأ
هو غالبًا بالأوضاع الحالية يكون فيها جزء من الخطأ
وفي المستقبل أعدلها، ما في أي عيب
الناحية الثانية اللي أنت وصفتها، هو أصلًا ما عنده علم
هو ما عنده طريقة علمية
لا بنى علاجه على دراسة أعضاء
لا بنى علاجه على دراسة أمراض، هو بنى علاجه...
أيش هو الطب الشعبي أو الطب البديل هو طب موروث
من ثقافة معينة، من عائلة معينة، من أب إلى ابن إلى آخره
بس هو يعالج أيش؟
هو علاج واحد وللا علاجين اللي بيعطيها لأي شيء
أنت بتتكلم اليوم مع طبيب
بيقول لك مثل ما قلت لك، نسبة كذا وفيه عندنا كذا
وأحيانًا أحصل كذا، ولما بندخل بالمنظار بنشوف كذا
ولو لقينا كذا؛ بنسوي كذا
هو عارف لأنه دارس كامل اللي موجود جوّا
أنا شايفه جراحيًّا، وشايفه بالمنظار، وشايفه بالأشعة؛ أنا متأكد منه
ومن الناحية الثانية، أنا عالجتهم بمئة
ما في أحد دخل عندي وما طلع متعالج. والله بتسمع
ما فيه مقارنة بهذا
فيه أخطاء؟ نعم فيه أخطاء
أنت اليوم عندك سيارة، الكفر حقها بنشر
أروح أمسك السيارة كلها أبيعها وأروح أشتري سيارة ثانية
وللا أروح أشتري سيكل! لا أنا أحل مشكلة الكفر
نعم، فيه خطأ هنا، فيه عيب هنا؛ بحل العيب
بس لا يجعل الباقي كله خطأ
ولا يجعل أن هذا أفضل، لا يمكن أن يكون اليوم
على الطاري، الإطارات المسطحة
بتحاول أنت تلاقي نفس الشيء في العلم
اليوم، عندك كل ما تطورت الأدوات
لأن لما نرجع إلى تعريف العلم الحقيقي في البداية
قلت لك، أنا أحاول بالأدوات اللي أملكها، أحاول أنقضه
وحتى الطب، شوف العلم تراكمي
أنت تتكلم من أيام «ابن سينا» «الرازي» والناس هذه
أنت لو تشوف الكتب حقهم، الكتب حقهم كانت تدرّس في أوربا
بس هي مبنية على أيش؟
هي مذكرات طبية أكثر من أنها كتب طب
بمعنى أن ملاحظة أثناء العلاج واطلاعه
«ابن سينا» كان محظوظ أن أُتيحت له الفرص
أن يقرأ كتب معينة، ويطّلع على ثقافات معينة
بحكم قربه كان من الحكام ذيك الأيام
فاطّلع وقرأ وشاف وكتب
والكلام الذي كتبه عظيم ومجهود عظيم
لكن هو ما كان علم ذيك الأيام، أشعة
ما كان عنده تحاليل، ما كان عنده منظار يقدر يدخل ويشوف
فهذا اللي يجعل العلم المحدود اللي قدمه
مقارنةً بالأدوات المحدودة في ذاك الوقت؛ يعتبر عبقري زمانه
لكن لا يعقل بأي حال من الأحوال استخدم «ابن سينا» في الزمن هذا
هو نفسه لو موجود الآن حي، بيقول لك لا يا حبيبي وقف!
اللي اكتشفناه جوّا مختلف على اللي أنا لاحظته
لأن هو بالملاحظة
وكان الطب نعم تراكمي استخدماته لأنه ملاحظ
مثال بسيط، زمان بعد الجراحة، لما كانوا يبدأوا في الجراحة
في القرن الثامن عشر، كيف كانوا يخيطوا الجرح؟
ما كان بخيط، كان يجيبوا رؤوس النمل الأبيض
ويكسروه ويحطوه غرز، رأس النمل الأبيض!
اليوم أنت لو بتسوي عملية جراحية
ترضى دكتور يحطل لك رأس نمل أبيض؟
«ابن سينا» كانوا هم زمان من مئات السنين، لا
هذا المنطق اللي أنا أتكلم فيه
الحين نجي إلى المنطق
إذا أخذنا أن اليوم فيه تعريف للطب البديل أو الطب الشعبي
وأنت تشوفه طب خربوطي
أنا ما شفته خربوطي
لا ممكن يؤخذ منه، أنا قلت لك فيه ممارسات
بيؤخذ منها أشياء تكون فعلًا لها أساس علمي
لها منطق في محاولة العلاج فيها
اليوم أقول لك الأدوية كثير مأخوذة من هناك
بس اللي احنا نتكلمه، أن اليوم اللي موجود ادعاءاته غير حقيقية
ادعاءات لا تصح بالمنطق، لا تصح بطرق العلم
ليش أنا بضيّع في النهاية مجهود ووقت ومال
ومصادر من مختلف الأماكن
عشان أثبت لك أن كوي اليد ما يعالج الجلطة في الدماغ
ما له علاقة، يعني ما بسويها أصلًا
شوف خلنا نتفق مثلًا أن الكي موضوع نتجاوزه
أنا بجي لسالفة، ليش أصلًا الناس والطب الحديث، يقول
أنه بيروح ياخذ الخلاصات
هو 40% من الأدوية مستخلص من أشياء طبيعية
ليش ما يبغون الأشياء الطبيعية تاخذها؟ لأن هو يبغى يكسب
وأنت تعرف أن شركات الأدوية عندها النفوذ العالي جدًّا
في كل المنظمات الصحية اللي تخلي هذا منطقي
لأنك إذا رحت وأخذت حبة سوداء، مين اللي يربح؟
العطار، الشركة ما تربح
فهي أشياء متاحة للجميع، صارت شيء عند شركة وحدة
وصار فيه أشياء كيماوية ممكن تأثر عليك سلبًا
ممكن تأثر عليك، لأن هذا طبيعي
وهذا مفهوم مغلوط ويزعّل
أيش يعني مادة كيميائية؟
اللي يجي في بال الشخص اللي نعرفه عن الكيمياء
عشان كل الناس تكره الكيمياء، ليش؟
مادتين وانفجر المعمل، هذا مفهوم الكيميائي، لا
الموية اليوم اللي نشربها هي عبارة عن «H2O»
هي مادة كيميائية، كل شيء في الدنيا فيه مادة كيميائية
كلمة كيميائي لا يجعله مشكلة إطلاقًا، تمام؟
حبيت
فهذا رقم واحد
رقم اثنين، الأدوية جميعها حتى اللي تطلعه من الأعشاب حتى الأغذية
كل شيء على المستوى الكيميائي هي مادة كيميائية، اتفقنا؟
متفقين
اليوم شركات الأدوية، نعم فيه نفوذ
وطبعًا فيه ضغط سياسي وفيه ضغط اقتصادي
نفهم هذا الكلام وكله موجود
بس أي شركة أدوية، بالذات في زمن الرأسمالية العظيم اللي احنا نعيشه
عارفة أن البقدونس فيه مادة تعالج الفشل الكلوي
بتخلي عبدالرحمن أبو مالح في بيته يغليه ويبيعه للناس؟
لا
وللا بتروح تاخذ البقدونس وتستخرج المادة
وتسجل حقوقه وتبيعها بالملايين؟ نقطة
فشركات الأدوية تهاجم عشان ما يبغوا العلاج ذا يطلع
هذا كلام ما هم عقلاني أصلًا
شركات الأدوية عندها القوة والمصادر
اللي تطلّع المادة وتسويه وتخلص
اليوم حتى المنافسة بين شركات الأدوية موجودة، وهذا واقع
أنا شخصيًّا ما عندي مشكلة أنك تكسب ماديًّا
سواءً كنت في قطاع الأدوية أو القطاع الصحي للعلاج
طالما بتقدم شيء في المقابل
مشكلتي لما آخذ منك فلوس
وأنا ما بقدم شيء في المقابل، أو بضحك عليك؛ هذا القضية
اليوم مثلًا شركة أدوية عندها علاج معين للصرع
جات شركة أدوية ثانية أو مختبر بحثي ثاني طلّع علاج أفضل
أنا بخسر، ماهو شركة الأدوية كيف شغالة؛ بخسر
ما بيقعد يستنى هو؛ لا، بيبدأ يشوف علاج ثالث
اليوم المختبرات البحثية أصلًا كيف شغالة؟
ترى كلها رعايات من شركات الأدوية
شركات الأدوية تروح تستثمر وتشوف ملخص بحثي
فكرة بحثية معينة ثبتت بطريقة معينة في المختبرات
تعرض على شركات الأدوية
شافتها مقنعة، شافت الطريقة حقتها، عندها فريق استشاري
وافقت؛ تبدأ تدعم ماليًّا مختبرات الأبحاث هذه
عشان تمشي في الخطوات العلمية
فهذا اللي قاعد يصير، تمامًا لما تسمعه
بالعكس سؤالك مره فنان
لأن فعلًا اللي نسمعه اليوم: هذه مواد كيميائية يحطوها في أجسامنا
كل شيء مواد كيميائية
لازم أن الناس تفهم، لا شيلوا من بالك الصورة النمطية
حق المواد الكيميائية والأشياء هذه كلها
لكل شيء مواد كيميائية
اليوم «الإنسولين» كان نستخرج من الحيوانات
ونعطيه الإنسان كعلاج
تعال «الإنسولين» هذا اللي بنستخرجه من الحيوان، طبيعي
نستخرجه ونحطه تحت المايكروسكوب ونحطه بالأجهزة حقتنا
ونطلّع مكوناته الكيميائية ونشوف هو عبارة عن أيش
احنا نقدر اليوم نحضّر نفس المركب في المختبر
مثل ما اليوم نقدر نحضّر موية في المختبر
هذا كله نقدر نحضره اليوم
بجيب نفس الذرات ترتبط بنفس الروابط بنفس الظروف
اليوم «الإنسولين» كله اللي موجود مُصنّع
ولكنه يحاكي ويطابق، بنفس المواصفات
أنت لازم لما تجي تنظر، تنظر...
أنا ما بتشعّب، بس اليوم كلنا نروح السوبرماركت
منتجات عضوية، منتجات عضوية صحية، هذا كلام فارغ
القيمة الغذائية، خليني أقول لك على حاجة
أنا أعطيك كلام العلم، ما أعطيك كلام العاطفة ولا كلام التجارة
المنتجات العضوية قيمتها الغذائية
لا يوجد فيها أي فرق عن المنتجات الغير عضوية
قول ثاني
شفت كيف!
فأنت اليوم بتدفع أكثر
شوف أتفهم الكلام ذا في دولة غير دولتنا، ليش أنا أفضّل العضوية؟
هي عشان رش المبيدات والأشياء ذي كلها
احنا عندنا «إف دي إيه» شوف أنا لا اشتغل معاهم
بس ترى جهة محترمة
هيئة الغذاء والدواء؟
هيئة الغذاء والدواء، شوف فيه فترة تحريم ما يقدر
رش مبيدات، ما يقدر أصلًا يحصد وللا يوزع
وللا يبيع في فترة التحريم
لازم تخلص الفترة وفيه فحص وفيه تحاليل بتصير قبل ما يبدأ
فأنت هنا إذا كانت هذه مشكلتك
فأنت في بلد مثل السعودية، الحمد لله، متجاوز المشكلة ذي
تبغى تروح تشتري كيلو طماطم بخمسة ريال أو بثلاثين ريال؛ أنت حر
بس أنا أقول لك، كقيمة غذائية هي وحدة
يجيني واحد يقول لي، بس الطعم في الفراولة، لا
والله العظيم، لو أجيب لك نفس المنتج
وأغمض عينك منت عارف هذا أيش وللا أيش؛ ما بتعرف
تبي تدفع ثلاثة أضعاف الرقم براحتك، بس أنا أعطيك العلم
العلم كقيمة غذائية هي وحدة بلا أي فارق
طيب دقيقة، الآن يقولون أن جزء كبير من الأمراض
خصوصًا السرطان وانتشاره بين الناس
هو من الأكل لأنه مليان كيماويات
شوف هذه مشكلة، السرطان مشكلة
قالوها في التوحد، وقالوها في السرطان
وقالوها في الأمراض، زادت الأمراض
هي مو زادت الأمراض، اليوم ما نقدر نجزم أن زادت الأمراض
احنا زاد عندنا القدرة على تشخيص الأمراض
زمان كانت الناس تموت، الين جيلنا
والله نام وما صحي، ما فيه شيء
رجع من العمل ونام وما صحي، مات
لا، هو فيه شيء، بس احنا ما كنا نعرف
التوحد اليوم، الأدوات، الأشعاعات، السرطانات
لا، احنا اليوم عندنا القدرة على تشخيص المرض بشكل أفضل
فهذا اللي فرق
أنت دائمًا تلاقي الدنيا أيش؟ يعكسوا، هذا الانحياز التأكيدي
أنت تقول أن ممكن كانوا زمان يموتوا من السرطان
بس ما كان يدري أن فيه سرطان؟
طبعًا، مو ما يدري، ما يقدر يشخّصه، كيف بيعرف!
ممكن يموت من السرطان، ممكن يموت من الحمى الشوكية
الحمى الشوكية من البلاوي اللي فتكت في الناس ما أحد عارف
وما أحد أصلًا يعرف خطر الحمى الشوكية
أنا نزلت تغريدة قبل كم يوم على الموضوع
لقيت ناس كثير فعلًا
يقول لك هذا هو نفسه اللي احنا ناخذه في الحج، هذا هو
ما أحد عارف أن هذا مرض خطير وموجود عندنا
وفيه ناس حارمين أبنائهم من التطعيمات
هذا ممكن نروحه في المناعة مو في الموضوع هذا
طيب، فيه ناس حاولوا أنهم يسوون تجارب محكمة
على علاجات شعبية وكانت نتائجها ممتازة
مثلًا «سيليولايت» فيه الكمادات التايلاندية، وكان أدائها ممتاز
كان عندك برضه «الإسكوندا» الإجهاد المزمن
وانخفض الإجهاد والتوتر عند الناس بنسبة واضحة
بناءً على تجارب باللي أنت تقول أنها علم حقيقي
صحيح. هذه التجارب هي تجارب أنا احترمها
بس هي تجارب مبدئية
ما أقدر آخذ من هنا وأروح أطبق على الناس
يلا خلاص، أعمم العلاج
اليوم أنت لو تدخل تشوف الكمادات التايلاندية بتلاقيها تنباع أونلاين
هذه ما أكملت مراحل البحث العلمي
مجمع لي عشرة أشخاص عامل عليهم بحث
هذا مو بحث، هذه بداية بحث
اثنين وعشرين واحد واحد صح
فيه بحث اثنين وعشرين شخص أنا أقيس عليهم العالم كله
بمختلف أجناسه وأعراق وجنسه، وحامل ومرضع وطفل
تخيل هذا اللي كنت أقول لك عليه
الخطر نفسه اللي صاير في الخلايا الجذعية
أنت قفزت على خطوات البحث العلمي
طيب أنت عارف بكرة أيش ممكن يكون ضرره؟ مصيبة
أنا أعطيك كارثة أكبر عشان تفهم الخطر فين
مرض السكر والخلايا الجذعية اللي تكلمت عنها
فيه علاج بالخلايا الجذعية كان لمرضى السكر، فيه ناس ادّعت عليه
وفعلًا تحقن الشخص بالخلايا الجذعية في البنكرياس
فعلًا يبدأ الإنسولين يشتغل، بس هنا المصيبة
شلون؟
هو لما نفهم احنا طبيعة المرض حق المرض السكري بالذات النوع الأول
هو مرض مناعي، فيه حاجة في المناعة اسمها انشغال المناعة
أنت لما تعطي له جسم ثاني من برّا
بتبدأ المناعة تخفض ضربها في البنكرياس
وتبدأ تلتفت للشيء الجديد هذا
فلما يقل العدد؛ أنت بتلاقي «الإنسولين» يبدأ يشتغل
بس هي مجرد فترة، خلّص هذا، حيّده المناعة؛ بيبدأ يرجع ويخرب هذا
أيش آثاره الجانبية؟
أنا ما بقول أن العلاج بالخلايا الجذعية خطأ
أنا بقول لا يصلح تجربته على الناس حاليًّا
الآن، شغال العلم فيه
هو طبعًا متجه للأسفل، لأن فيه بدائل طلعت أحسن منه مليون مرة
أوقات يفشل أو يسقط، والاهتمام فيها يقل
ولكن بشكل عام مجملًا، لما تبغى تجرب في العلاجات هذه
فيه مراكز بحثية محترمة
تعطيك أيش الخطوات العلمية اللي يمشوا عليها، وأيش المتوقع
ولو لا سمح الله، طلع لك شيء من الأعراض اللي ممكن تطلع
هم متكفلين بعلاجك
ففيه بروتوكول تمشي عليه
مو جاني واحد في الشارع وعطاني خلطة
أنا أحد قريباتي توفت بخلطة من الخلطات
أنا أتكلم من واقع حال، ومن واقع علم
ومن واقع تجربة، ومن واقع تخصص
هذه الأشياء تضر، والمشكلة في ضررها
اليوم لما تقول لي يا أخي الإبر الصينية فأيش ضرّت الناس؟
صح
أيش ضرّتك؟ إبر صينية، لا
فيه تجارب كثيرة ترى، فيه تجارب حق «هارفرد» 18 ألف
طيب ممتاز،  أيش طلع نتائج الدراسة؟
أنها تنفع في التحكم بالألم في أسفل الظهر؛ ما نختلف
احنا قلنا أول شيء أن الطبيب يعالج سبب المرض
قد يعالج بعض الأعراض
ولكن أساس فكرته علاج سبب المرض، هذا واحد
رقم اثنين، هي الفكرة فين؟
إذا أنت فيه آلالام في ظهرك وتبي تروح تسوي إبر صينية
سوِّ إبر صينية
لكن لا تعتقد أن الإبر الصينية هذه لما صُنعت من أجله
بمعنى، الأبر الصينية أيش فكرتها؟
هي فكرتها أن في «شاكرات» و لما تحط الإبر في الأماكن هذه
تفتح لك «الشاكرات» وتمشّي لك مسارات داخلك
هذه الأمور بتخليك بكرة لما يجي لا سمح الله
مرض داخلي في الجسم وللا في الظهر وللا كذا
لا، روح أسوي إبر صينية
هذا مو صح، أنت هنا بتتأخر عن العلاج، بتحرم نفسك من العلاج
«ستيف جوبز» كيف مات «ستيف جوبز»؟
بنفس الطريقة وهو «ستيف جوبز» المفترض متعلم وعارف
سرطان بنكرياس، تعال العملية فيها نسبة نجاح
بصير نباتي
نباتي وراح بدأ في علاجات الطاقة وما الطاقة هذه
ورجع متأخر، قالوا خلاص المرحلة الرابعة، كل سنة وأنت طيب
هذه الأمور ليش لأن هذه الأمور تتصاعد
تخلي الواحد اليوم بديت بـ«يوقا»
هو بدي بـ«يوقا» للاسترخاء
لكن صارت لا، أنا عندي «شاكرا» للرقبة أو عندي «شاكرا» حق البطن
أنا عندي التهاب في بطني أو آلام مغص بطني
أنا أروح أجلس «يوقا» عشان أعالج «الشاكرا» حقها
أيش هي «الشاكرا»؟
هو عندهم بوابات في الجسم للطاقة، يسموها «الشاكرا»
أنا خلاص صرت خبير، ممكن أعلمك شوي ونفتح مع بعض مشروع
حتى الشباب شوفهم بيضحكوا، بندخلكم معانا عشان الحسد
إيه، يدخلوا هنا ويتركوا الشركة
إذا أنت بتسوي شركة، وبتسويها إبر صينية
مو أنت تقولوا أن في السعودية ما يصير البهللة ذي
تقدر تسوّي شركة للإبر الصينية في السعودية
لا، السعودية ما عندها مشكلة
هي المشكلة مو في الممارسة، المشكلة في الادعاء
اليوم أنا أدّعي أنها تعالج أيش؟
اليوم الإبر الصينية تفضل، مركز التخسيس بالإبر الصينية، هذا أيش؟
يدغزك حتى تنحف
إيه شفت! اليوم البحث العلمي اللي أثبته، أثبت أنه يُعالج أسفل الظهر
أيش الادعاءات اللي صارت؟
لا، يسوي تخسيس ومدري إيه
شفت هذا الخطر
ناخذ حاجة ثانية، في السعودية عندنا المركز الوطني للطب البديل
للطب البديل نعم
وفي منظمة الصحة العالمية تعترف فيه، هو إيه؟!
أنا مين مقابل ذا
صدق والله، لأن هذا العلم
الحكومات ماودها تخاطر بحياة الناس عشان فلان وللا علتان
المركز الوطني للطب البديل، أنا شخصيًّا أعرف سبب إنشاءه
أنا قريب من صانع القرار وقت صناعة إنشاءه
متى أُنشئ؟
قبل خمسة أو ستة سنين في هذا الحدود
شفت أنا قلت لك أنا كبرت وماني مثل زمان
هذا المركز ما أُنشئ...
لو تشرب يانسون؛ كان ذاكرتك صارت...
إيه والله، صح صادق
بس ما أقدر أعالج الزهايمر والخرف باليانسون
أنا ما عندي مشكلة، شفت الفرق؟ هذا الفرق
المركز الوطني للطب البديل أنشئ لتنظيم الممارسات حق العلاج
الحجامة نحن وصلنا...
فيه مراكز حجامة موجودة ومرخصة
قبل المركز الوطني أيش كان؟ كان تحت الدرج
واحد منت عارف أدوات من فين جابها، من تعرف هو أيش أصلًا
فوضى عارمة وبؤر لانتشار الأمراض المعيدة بطريقة...
المركز أنشئ لتنظيم الكلام هذا كله
أنا مشكلتي الآن وقت ما تبغى تسوي حجامة؛ سوِّ حجامة
بس تعال شوف...
أنا مشكلتي الحقيقية، وهذا شوف أنا...
معالي وزير الصحة الأستاذ «فهد الجلاجل»
أنا أعرف أن هذا الموضوع من المواضيع اللي على مكتبه
هو شخص نشيط، الله يعينه ويساعده
شخص قائد حقيقي شغال في عدة اتجاهات وعدة ملفات
وهذه من الملفات اللي أنا أعرف أنها تهمه
اليوم تعال وشوف القائمة في مراكز الحجامة
يا رجل! تعالج الجيوب الأنفية والصداع والشلل النصفي
والإيدز والسرطان والبرستاتا وضعف مش عارف إيه
قائمة مخيفة
طيب هي تعالج أيش ؟
إلى الآن ما ثبت أنها تعالج شيء
طيب تنشطك؟ تشيل الدم الفاسد؟
شوف حبة حبة، أنت لا تعطيني
أنا معطيك الأشياء اللي أعرفها، بس صدق هذا...
وحدة، وحدة لأن كل ادعاء مصيبة أكبر من اللي قبله
لو فيه قطرة دم فاسد في جسمك؛ كانت تموت في لحظة
ما في شيء اسمه دم فاسد
ناس تقول لك دم فاسد، ناس تقول لك دم مستعمل بكثرة
أيش  يعني دم مستعمل بكثرة؟ استعمال حشمة يعني؟ وللا ...
أيش يعني دم مستعمل بكثرة؟
كل شوية يطلعوا لك شيء، مافي شيء مثل كذا في جسم الإنسان
ممكن أنك تطلّع الدم عشان جسمك يفرز دم جديد؟
هذه من الأشياء، بس كمية الدم اللي تطلع في الحجامة ماهو...
كم قرام؟
ما تتجاوز حتى 50 مللي. طبعًا هي أكواب صغيرة، ويقول لك الدم...
لو تبرعت بدمي أحسن؟
طبعًا. شوف هذه نقطة مرة مهمة
تتبرع لدمك عشان أتعالج من مرض
هذا غير موجود إلا في ثلاثة أمراض
فيه ثلاثة أمراض مشكلتها في تراكم حديد
في ثلاثة أو أربعة أمراض أشياء معروفة طبييًّا
هذا نعم، تحتاج مو تتبرع بالدم لأحد
لا، تتبرع بالدم والدم حقك يترمي، حتى ما ينفع أحد
هذا طريقة علاج، لكن أن أنا أتعالج
هي بتنشط نخاع العظم وتنتج دم جديد
بس هل هي تعالج مرض؟ هنا أنا عندي المسألة
وللا النوم مثلًا، أنام كثير
أنا أيش بقول لك، هذا ندخل في «النيوسيبو» و«البلاسيبو» ثاني مرة
أها، ممكن كذا
ما في إثبات. الحجامة اُشبعت بحث
لأن الحجامة هي طب فرعوني
من أيام الفراعنة ما هي حاجة جديدة عندنا
من أكثر من 5000 سنة و 7000 سنة
أنت تتكلم كونها أنها تمارس اليوم
هي تجي أتوقع في شيء اسمه الطب النبوي أو شيء مثل كذا؟
الطب النبوي هو طب شعبي
ولكن يوجد من ألبس عباءة الدين لحمايته من الانتقاد والانتفاع المالي
لكن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم، ما بُعث طبيب
ولا أدّعى في يوم أنه طبيب، ولا أدّعى أنه يعالج
بالعكس كان يقول اِيتِ «الحارث بن كلدة»
الطبيب اللي في ذلك الوقت يعالج، بس الناس...
بس كان يَستخدم ما يُستخدم وقته
إيه هذا هو طبعًا كان اللي موجود عنده
كان يقول شوف، جرّب
هذا من علوم الحياة إلا اللي الرسول اصلى الله عليه وسلم نفسها
قال «أنتم أعلم فيها بأمر دنياكم»
لكن فيه ناس عشان أحمي الانتقاد؛ لازم أحط لك...
يعني كلاسيكية، بس الآن وعي الناس جميل في الموضوع هذا
اختلف كثيرًا
ما تحجّمت؟
تحجمت خمسة مرات
والله؟ ليش طيب؟
أجرب
فادك؟ حسيتها حلوة؟
في البداية مرتين وقعت في شَرك «البلاسيبو»
حسيت أني مرتاح، آلالام ظهري خفت
بس بعد كذا ما عاد اشتغلت معايا
الحين كل هذه الأشياء...
وحتى الإبر الصينية جربتها
شوف أنا أتكلم علميًّا وأتكلم تجريبيًّا برضه
ماني جاني أنظّر على الناس
وعشان بكرة واحد يقول لك والله شفناه في مكان يسوي
حتى لو ما جربت وأنت تعرف المعلومة بغض النظر
إيه بس أنا بقولك، مو لازم أجربها صحيح
بس فيه الأشياء اللي متاحة
لأن أنا أبغى أعرف الوصف اللي أسمعه من الناس
حسيت أني إنسان جديد
طيب أبغى أروح وأصير إنسان جديد حتى؛ ما في
والادعاءات اللي تدخل عند أي محجّم، ادخل وتفرج
المشكلة عندي من جديد، ماهو في الممارسة
طالما الممارسة منظمة ومراقبة
عشان لا يصير فيها عدوى أو شيء، فما عندي مشكلة
فأنت تبغى تروح؟ روح، إذا يريحك روح
اليوم «مايو كلينك» لو قلت لهم بسوي حجامة؛ تسوي حجامة
بس هم ما يُقرّوه كعلاج
يُقرّوه كأيش؟
هو أنت لما ترتاح عليه، يكون علاج تكميلي للعلاجات اللي بتاخذها
روح وخذها
فهو علاج تكميلي طيب؟
هو أنت إذا ترتاح عليه
لا دقيقة، أنا لو ارتاح للبطاطس ما بيسوي لي بطاطس في المستشفى
هو كذا بيسويها حاجة علاجية في المستشفى، و«مايو كلينك»...
«مايو كلينك» والأماكن هذه
أي ممارسة طبية ماهي ممنوعة في البلد
وحاب أن تسويها؛ سويها ما عندي مشكلة
بس تجي تقول له في البروتوكول العلاجي عندك
فيه حجامة، وللا فيه زمزم، وللا فيه كذا؛ يقول لك ما عندي، أنا آسف
هل ممكن أي طبيب يوصي بالحجامة؟
لو كان واقع في...
لا، صدق طبيًّا، سيبك أنه واقع في فكرة، أن هو أصلًا مؤمن أن لها قيمة
لا، نتكلم طبيًّا
لا، ما فيه
مو مستحيل؟
وللا كان أنشأنا عيادة حجامة في وسط المستشفى
جنب عيادة الأعصاب وعيادة...
همك تقول الحين
لا، هذه مراكز حق حجامة محطوطة في...
فيه كلام الواحد ما ينفع يقوله، بس عمومًا هي...
عشان الفلوس اللي يجيبوناها وللا أيش قصدك؟
مين هم؟
«مايو كلينك» وغيرهم
لا، ما لهم علاقة. أنت بتجيب على حسابك
بس هو يكسب مني
من هو اللي بيكسب منها؟
المراكز ذي
لا، هي تجيب. أنت اليوم في «مايو كلينك»
أنت المريض بتتعالج لمرض معين
وتطلب أبغى أسوي حجامة أو إبر صينية
هل هذه الممارسة مسموحة ومنظمة في البلد؟
خذ وجرّب
بس ما بيضرك أنا كطبيب؟
لو ممنوعة في البلد
مثلًا الدخان مو ممنوع، بس ما في طبيب يسمح لك تدخّن
لا، هذا ما له علاقة باللي أنا أقوله
لأن الدخان مضر
إيه، وما يستخدم كعلاج، لا في طب بديل ولا في طب حديث
إلا إذا أنت عندك معلومة ثانية أنا ما أعرفها!
بقول لك على علاج يقوّي النظر، بس هو ثاني
قصدي أن لو الحجامة والإبر الصينية مضرة؛ كان مستحيل يسمح فيها
أنا طبيب، أنا مؤتمن على صحتك، لا يمكن أن أسمح لك
أتفق
تبغى تسويها اطلع برّا، أنا غير مسؤول عنها
لا، إذا كانت مضرة
إيه
ما أحد قال لي. أنا من جديد، قلت لك أنا ما عندي مشكلة في الممارسة
عندي مشكلة في ادعاءاتها، في الادعاءات اللي تدّعى من أجلها
اليوم أنا بدل ما أدّعي أن هذه الإبر للتخسيس
أنا أسويها للتخسيس مثلًا أو تعالج السرطان
هذه هي المشكلة، الناس بتتوقف عن العلاج بيها وبتروح
بشكل عام، فيه فترة جاتنا واحدة دكتورة
ادّعت العلاج بالأبوال والأبل والأشياء هذه كلها للسرطان
احنا فيه بحث بنشره عما قريب، إن شاء الله
سواه الدكتور «محمد شاهين»
بحالات مصابة بالسرطان، وكيف الحالات هذه بدأت في المستشفى
وتم تشخيصها بالسرطان ووضعها
وكان بسهولة ممكن علاجها
تركت وراحت سمعت كلام الدكتورة هذه
وبدأوا في كورسات العلاج بالألبان والأبوال
ثلاثة عشر حالة كلها ماتت
لا إله إلا الله
كلها، هذا خطر. هذا نتكلم عليه أن احنا...
أنا اليوم أيش خسران لما تكون الحجامة شغالة؟
بالعكس  لو شغالة وتعالج؛ الطب ياخذها ويضيفها من البرتوكول حقه
بس هو ما يحب الأشياء الشعبية
هي مالها علاقة، أنا قلت لك
هذه طالعة عند الهند، احنا أمريكان ما ناخذها
ما لك لهم، مو صحيح
معقولة ولا شيء من اللي كانوا يسوونه زمان صار ينفع دحين!
لا، أنا بقولك فيه علاج الملاريا اليوم
من أعشاب أصلًا كانت تستخدم في الهند وفي الصين
علاج الملاريا، بس اليوم أنا أيش بسوي؟
أنا أخذت المادة الفعالة وعرفت الجرعات حقك مع عمرك
مع التجارب، عرفت في العمر تعطيك كذا في العمر
أعراضه الجانبية كذا، ترى يضبط على العدد ذا وما يضبط على العدد ذا
هذا اللي قاعد يصير، فما هو عيب
بس أنت برضه تصورهم أنهم مرة يحبوا الخير وكذا
كأنهم خيّرين أن أنا جالس أسويها عشان صحتك
لا، قلت لك طالما بعطيك فائدة؛ من حقي يا أخي أكسب
ترى ماني فاتح كمان جمعية خيرية
أنا ما عندي مشكلة في هذا الموضوع إطلاقًا
في؟
أن أحد يتكسب، ولكن لا تتكسب وأنت تبيعني وهم
ولا تتكسب وأنت بتضرني
لا، بالعكس مفترض أكثر الناس تتكسب فلوس
هم الدكاترة واللي يصنعوا الدواء
إذا واحد بيشفيني وما ياخذ فلوس، أجل من اللي ياخذ الفلوس؟!
خلني أصدمك بشيء، حتى في داخل التخصصات الطبية
اليوم مثلًا لما يكون عندي جراح زراعة أعضاء وجراح تجميل
شوف كصعوبة، زراعة الأعضاء شيء يطلع الشيء من رموشك
من كثرة صعوبته ودقته، والوقت اللي تستغرقه كل عملية
ولا يقارن ولا حتى بمثل 20% من دخل التجميل
فهي حتى في هذه فيه فئات من الدكاترة الجراحين ما بياخذوا
الدخل المالي لا يوازي قيمة المجهودات
ما أعلاه فيستحق
والطب بأمانة مهما تقول ومهما تسمع قصص
أنا ثمانية عشر سنة خدمت في القطاع الحكومي
في القطاع الخاص وفي القطاع التجاري الصحي
وفي قطاع المشاريع على مستوى الدولة فيما كانت بتحقيق الرؤية
مهما تسمع قصص؛ الطب والتخصصات الطبية
تراها فعلًا تخصصات إنسانية بالدرجة الأولى
وترى الشخص يراعي فيها، أنا أتكلم بشكل عام
الحالات الشادة لا تجعل أن هذا هو السواد الأعظم
لا، مو صحيح
أنت مثلًا حاط نعناع في الموية، ليش؟
طعم
بس؟
إيه، لأنها موية غازية
طعم
لا، لأنها تشيل البكتيريا الضارة، ففيها بكتيريا نافعة
أيوة؟
والنعناع يزيد مضاعفاتها، يخلي التركيز أعلى
طيب، مو مشكلة، أنت مبسوط؟
بس ما تعالجك من شيء؟ ما تعمل لك تخلّص من السموم؟
لا، تخليني أقدر أركز معاك
إيه، أنا صح أحتاجها
شوف أنا فقدت التركيز
إيه تاخذ نعناع
بس ما تعمل لك تخلص من السموم أهم شيء
لا، ما تسوّي
ولا غسيل قولون
إلا، على خفيف
أنت عارف أن هذا كله كلام فاضي
أدري والله
طيب ما قلت لي على منظمة الصحة العالمية
أيش بها منظمة الصحة العالمية؟
يجي المركز العالمي للطب الشعبي، أيش رأيك فيه؟
نفس الشيء
نفس الفكرة، تنظيم...
اليوم منظمة الصحة العالمية
أنت تقصد المركز الوطني حق الطب البديل؟ وللا تقصد الـ «آي سي دي»؟
«آي سي دي»
طبعًا شوف عشان أكون معاك واضح
الـ «آي سي دي» هو نظام ترميز طبي
نظام أكواد لتوحيد الأمراض، ويكون كل مرض له كود وآليات تشخيصها
أن أنت عندك المرض هذا معناته تشخيصه كذا وكذا
عشان شركات التأمين والمطالبات والأشياء ذي كلها تتوحد
في كل مكان في العالم
في آخر نسخة اللي هي «آي سي دي 11»
هم أضافوا، للأسف طبعًا، الطب الصيني معهم
وأنا أقول لك ليش للأسف
طبعًا هم أضافوها وكتبوا بالبنط العريض
أن احنا لا ندعو لأي شكل من أشكال...
لا نسوّق أنها بتعالج وموجودة فقط للإحصائيات
عشان الأمراض الثانية والطب الحديث يستفيد من الإحصائيات
هذا منظمة الصحة
مثل ما أنت قلت أول، عندنا فيه الضغط الاقتصادي والضغط السياسي
دخل هو أيام كانت وحده اسمها «مارقريت تشان» الظاهر
اللي هي مديرة منظمة الصحة العالمية، هي صينية
دخلت وصار المجتمع العلمي إلى اليوم شاب عليهم
على أن حتى لو؛ احنا ما نبغاها كإحصائيات، ليش؟
اليوم الشخص اللي من بعيد ينظر للموضوع
هو بيفهم وبيعتقد خطأ أن هذا اعتراف بها كعلاج، وهذا مو صحيح
لأن فيه ممارسات كثيرة أصلًا تضر البشر، تضر الناس، فيها مواد سامة
وفيه حالات ماتت ومسجل
فأنت اليوم لما تحطها تقول لي هي إحصائيات
أصلًا احنا ما قررناها كعلاج؛ ما تحطها
هذه الأشياء والنتائج العكسية في يوم من الأيام
بترجع وبتسوي مشكلة
وإن شاء الله، واحنا موجودين في صحة وعافية تتذكر كلامي هذا
هذا خطأ جسيم ارتكبته منظمة الصحة العالمية
ولو ما تراجعت عنه؛ بتدفع ثمنها من صحة الناس الكثير
في الطب الحديث قبل نروح إلى المناعة
برضه هو مو كله تمام وللا؟
أيش مو كله تمام؟
الأدوية اللي تجي بعضها مو متأكدين منها 100% صح؟
مثل أيش؟
مثل هذه الإبر اللي تنحف الحين، «منجارو» وللا؟
عرفتها؟
أيوة، على أساس أن ماهي هي؟ هي معمولة لسبب
أنا أول لما قلت لك على خطوات البحث العلمي، قلت لك نقطة
ليس كل شيء ينجح مع الإنسان، ينجح مع كل الناس
لذا هنا دور الطبيب اللي يصف هذا الإبر هو اللي يعرف
مو أختي نحفت؛ أبغى أروح أسوي مثلها
الإبر أتوقع أنها تؤخذ من الصيدلية وللا؟
لا، لازم وصفة، فيما أعلم لازم وصفة
لا، ما تنباع من الصيدلية
أنا أقول لك فيما أعلم
بس عمومًا أن أغلب الناس تقدر تاخذها
على حسب الحالة الصحية للشخص، طبعًا هم...
أنا ما أعرف عنها كثير، بس كنت أسولف مع صديق
وبرضه كان فيه ضيف تكلم عنها
فكنت أسأله كيف، ومدري أيش ومثل كذا
فكان يقول ما أحد يعرف أيش آثارها الجانبية، بس أنها تنحّف إلى الآن
طيب يا حلو، أنت...
مبدئيًّا لا، ما في أحد ما يعرف. يقول لك ما تعرف أيش بيكون للآن
المعلومات اللي عندنا للآن أنها آمنة وتنفع
حتى أعراضها الجانبية مدروسة، ولو صارت أعراضها الجانبية...
فكيف يخلون الناس تستخدمها طيب؟
أنا بقولك مدروسة معروفة
اليوم أيّ شيء له أعراض جانبية، بس هذا ميزة العلم
أنا أقول لك، اليوم إذا أخذت حبة «بنادول»
ممكن يصير لك في جرعة معينة كذا
هذا أنا أعرف العرض الجانبي وأعرف أتعامل معاه
بالعكس هذا قوة العلم
هذا لا يعني أن احنا ما نعرف
لا، هذا يؤكد أننا نعرف الدواء هذا أيش وفين رايح
لو كان فيه شخص، لعل أنا ما سمعت، ولكن...
لا، كان ضيف ما له علاقة، كنا نتكلم عن الكمبيوتر وكذا
بس أن هو نحف، فيقول أني استخدمتها، ما نتكلم طبيًّا
يصير بالتالي ما في حاجة اسمها ما همهم عارفين أيش هو
لا، أنا كواحد يستخدمها على الأرجح 99% الحين جلس أكيّس لك
أنهم ما يدرون أيش أعراضها الجانبية أصلًا
حتى يمكن الأطباء ما يعرفون
لا، مستحيل الطبيب ما يعرف، مستحيل
يقول لك بنجرب، يمكن نشوف بعد عشرين سنة أيش يصير لكم، ما أعرف
وأنت على أي أساس افترضت أن بعد عشرين سنة بيصير شيء؟
ما أدري
بهذه الآلية احنا ولا شيء بناخذه في حياتنا
وما أعرف والله أنا لو شربت الموية بالنعناع حقتك هذه
بعد عشرين سنة أيش بيصير؟
ممكن تسبب لي أساس بداية مرض، ما تقدر تقول
لا، بس لأنها ما سوّت لي حاجة، بس هذه لعبت في دماغي
أنت أيش عرفك بعد عشرين سنة أيش بيصير!
بنفس المنطق أنا قاعد أرد عليك وأؤكد أنه مو منطقي
بس هذا لأني جالس ألعب في جسمي
لأن أنا لما أخذت الإبرة
أنا جالس أخلي جسمي يحس أني شبعان طول الوقت
فأنا سويت شيء غلط أصلًا، لعبت على جسمي
بينما لما أشرب موية
احنا مثل ما قلنا، هي عدت الأساسات حق الأمان، وحق النجاعة
وعلى مختلف الناس وللا ما أُقرّت
قد يحدث بكرة، عشان كذا دائمًا الـ«إف دي بي» في العالم كله
فاتح الأبواب، أي دواء مفسوح
لأنه صار، جات فترة أدوية عدت تجارب البحث العلمي
وطلع فيها مشكلة وانسحبت
صار فيها مشكلة، ليش؟
أنت تقني معلومات وعارف، في النهاية في عندك تصحيح الأخطاء
مرحلة تصحيح الأخطاء اللي بتصير أنت لازم تكون عندك عدد
اليوم شركات الأجهزة هذه لما تنزّل...
مو على حسي
إيه، مو أنت ما تعرف. هي مو على حسك
أنا سويت كل اللي أقدر عليه اليوم عشان أطلع لك العلاج
ما في شيء في العلم أنا قصرت فيه
أو فيه طريقة معينة كان لازم نسويها وتجاوزتها
بالعكس احنا اليوم ضد تجاوز أي خطوة من خطوات البحث العلمي
طيب واللي صار مع كورونا؟
أيش صار مع كورونا؟
لقاح طلع كذا مثل ما يقولوا
أيش اسم الشركة الأمريكية؟
قصدك «فايزر» وللا
لا، مو «فايزر» الثانية
«موديرنا»
إيه، «موديرنا» سووه في كم؟ في جمعة
لا، لا
في يوم زمان، في أسبوع
طلعت النتيجة وقدروا يسوونه
هم كانوا الظاهر استخدموا الذكاء الاصطناعي برضه
فقدروا يطلعوه في وقت وجيز
يطلعوه أيش قصدك؟ كتصنيع أولي؟ كالشكل الأولي؟
اللي هو طلع علينا بعدين
لا، بس أنت لازم تكون فاهم نقطة
أنت لازم تكون عارف اللقاح، أيش مراحل تصنيعه في الوقت الطبيعي
بياخذ خمس سنوات، وهذا أسرع لقاح تسوّى في خمس سنوات
اللي هو «الإيبولا» قبل كورونا طبعًا
ممتاز
اللي صار في كورونا، التقنية حق التطعيم نفسه مختلفة تمامًا
تقنية جديدة
أيش اللي يخلي التطعيمات تاخذ خمسة أو عشرة سنين عشان تطلع؟
حاجتين: التمويل
والموافقات الحكومية؟
لا، هذا آخر شيء. أتكلم من البداية التمويل
فترة التجارب اللي بحتاجها لأن العدد اللي عندي
أنا في مختبر بحثي كان عندي؟ عشرة أو خمسة عشر شخص
اللي صار في كورونا موضوع ثاني
اللي صار في كورونا تمويل انفتح من كل دول العالم وحكومات
اللي صار في كورونا كل مختبرات العالم اشتغلت مع بعض
عشان تطلّع الموضوع ذا
فأنت هذا اختصر لك، زائد أن التقنية الجديدة
تختصر وقت من وقت المختبر
الأشياء اللي كانت تتحضر في المختبر وتسوي جودة
وشيء يضبط وشيء ما يظبط
هذا اختصرت لك إياه بشكل كبير؛ عشانها بتقنية حديثة
فهذا اللي خلى تطعيم كورونا يطلع
واليوم ما في تجربة إكلينيكية في العالم
صارت بحجم لقاح كورونا أنه آمن
الأعداد اللي تطعمت هي أكبر دليل أنه بالعكس ناجح وآمن
طيب، فيه شيء ثاني برضه على الطب الحديث، أو العلم الحديث
تجاوزه، أو ااكتشفوا أنه خطأ في الدراسة ويجربوا علينا
اللي هو موضوع الكمامة برضه
فما كان لها قيمة، بعدين طلع أن لها قيمة
بعدين يسويها أو ما يسويها، بعدين طلع الحين
أن الفيروس ما يمديك تسيطر عليه إلا في الغرف المسكّرة اللي في المستشفى
على كورونا؟
إيه
فطلع أن الكمامة، هم كانوا يقولون في كل العالم
أنه؟
أن لازم تسويها، وطلع مالها قيمة
لا، هي لها قيمة، بس كيف؟
فيه واحد كان يقول أن حتى لو مو تستخدم «3 إم» لو تستخدم «5 إم»
أنت عشان هذا؛ لازم تكون في الغرفة اللي في المستشفىات
العزل
المعزولة، إذا منت في غرفة معزولة
أنت معرض أن يجي، لأنه ينتشر عبر الهواء
لا، مو صحيح. أول شيء ما ينتشر عبر الهواء
كورونا ينتشر عن طريق الرذاذ
والرذاذ ثقيل يطلع ويسقط الأرض
متأكد؟
طبعًا متأكد، هذا تخصصي، كيف مو متأكد!
ما بضحك عليك، لا بعطيك الواقع، فهذا واحد
رقم اثنين، الكمامة ما تحميك من أنك تاخذ عدوى كورونا
بمعنى شوف هذه النقطة اللي لعلها هي اللي صنعت الالتباس
أنت لو مصاب بكورونا، خليها فيك أنت، ما أبغاها فيني أنا
وأنا لابس كمامة، وجيت كحيت أو عطست أمامي
هل الكمامة بتحميني؟ لا
ولكن العكس صحيح
لو أنت مصاب بكورونا ولابس كمامة وأنا سليم
وكحيت أو عطست في الكمامة نفسها
نعم، أنا نسبة أن يجيني عدوى جدًّا منخفضة
لأن الرذاذ هذا هي ما بتطلع فيروس فيروس
هي بتطلع رذاذ، نقاط مع بعض، فبتلصق في الكمامة وما بتطلع
فهي تحمي، ولكن مو بالطريقة اللي شُرحت للناس
طبعًا، لما تتكلم أنت على مستوى دولة
أنا ما بتكلم مين مصاب ومن مو مصاب
كله يلبس كمامة
لما تتعامل على مستوى الشعوب؛ بيختلف عن تعامل الأفراد
وبعدين الكمامة اللي كانت تستخدمها الناس هي المشكلة
طريقة استخدام الناس في الكمامة هي كانت المشكلة
حابب يفسخها ويحطها على طاولة المطعم
وبعدين يلبسها مرة ثانية نفسها
وللا أنت تورطت وتبي تدخل مكان ومقفلينها بـ«توكلنا» ولازم كمامة
وأفسخ كمامة خذ الكمامة وانزل بسرعة جيب وتعال
هذه مصايب
هذه ما لها علاقة في دولة ولا علاج ولا مناعة
هذا لحالهم كذا
لأنني أتذكر، بس ممكن نحطها في النشرة
لأنها معلومة طبية بتأكد منها
أتذكر أني قرأت أنهم يسمونها محمولة على الجو مو رذاذ
أنا حاولت أطلعها الحين، بس ما أقدر أطلعها بسرعة
أن إذا هو بالهواء وللا بتحط كمامتك
بس يمكن لو تعدّل الكمامة وتخليها غير قابل للخروج
أنا فهمت عليك الآن
في وحدة من التجارب اللي صارت في أيام كورونا، جربوا جهاز التنفس
جهاز التنفس هذا يطلع لك مثل الرذاذ
لو طلع كورونا باستخدام الجهاز هذا
بيطلع مو مثل الرذاذ، بيطلع في الهواء
بيكون فيه قطرات صغيرة جدًّا، بينتشر
لكن هذه ما كانت أصلًا واقع الفيروس، ولا كانت لها علاقة بالفيروس
هذه تجربة علمية سووها
وما لها علاقة إطلاقًا بالفيروس نفسه ولا بطبيعة الفيروس
فهي تجربة علمية كانت في فترة كورونا
ليس لها علاقة بطبيعة الفيروس
بس أنا كنت بحاول أقول أن العلم الحديث مو قرآن
مو قرآن، ولا أي علم في الدنيا قرآن، احنا ما نقول كذا
شوف  عشان لا يكون فيه مغالطة
ترى الطب الشعبي أتوقع قادر على أن يقول
أنا أجرب أكثر من الطب الحديث
طبعًا، بس برضه قاعد يقتل ويضر أكثر من الطب الحديث، طبعًا مختلف
والأخطاء الطبية تقتل أكثر من ما أدري أيش
لا، شوف أنت قفزت هنا قفزة مختلفة
أنا لما أسألك اليوم أيش يعني أخطاء طبية؟ أيش بتفهم؟
ما أدري والله ممكن إهمال، دكتور نسي زرادية
هذا المفهوم حق الأخطاء الطبية
هذا مو الواقع
أيش الواقع؟
الأخطاء الطبية هي مجموعة من الممارسات
شوف أي شخص يتعرض لضرر أو موت داخل المستشفى
وداخل المنشأة الطبية يعتبر أخطاء طبية
حتى فيه دراسة طلعت نكبتنا في حياتنا الدراسية
عشان تقعد تشرحها للناس ودراسة حقيقية هي فعلًا
أن الأخطاء الطبية ثالث أكبر سبب الوفاة في العالم
هذه للأسف، تم فهمها بشكل خاطئ، ليش؟
أول شيء، خلنا نفهم أن الدراسة اللي سووها علماء
بطريقة علمية ببحث علمي، ما نختلف في الموضوع
ثانيًا، الغرض من الدراسة أيش كان؟
الغرض من الدراسة كان لفت انتباه الحكومات ووجهات التمويل
أن المستشفيات تحتاج تطوير في بيئاتها وفي أفرادها
لأنه فيه أخطاء كثير بتصير؛ فلازم تدفعوا
والدراسة كانت ذكية
الأهم من هذا كله
تعال، أيش هي الأخطاء الطبية
وهنا نحتاج أن ندخل في العمق شوية
خليني أقسم لك إياها على أربعة أشياء أساسية
واحد، إهمال، شخص مهمل
أنا بعطيك هي كرؤوس أقلام وبعدين أعالج لك هي
السبب الثاني، ضعف إداري في المنشأة
مما أدى إلى أن المنشأة غير مهيئة
أو الأفراد ما هم كفاءة بالشكل الكافي
أو المنشأة أصلًا ما تقدر تقدم الخدمة الطبية بكل أشكالها
فهذه النقطة الثانية، اللي يطلع منها أخطاء
النقطة الثالثة، اللي هي الأعراض الجانبية للعلاجات، للعمليات الجراحية
التهاب جراح، صار تسمم في مدري إيه
فهذه النقطة الثالثة في الأخطاء الطبية
النقطة الرابعة، اللي هي تدهور الحالة الطبية بعد دخولها للعلاج
هذه كلها الآن مسمى أخطاء طبية
كل الأموات اللي صاروا بهذه طالعين في الدراسة
فطبعًا أرقام كبيرة جدًّا
لكن لا تمثل المفهوم اللي احنا فاهمنيه حق الإهمال
الإهمال بزعمي موجود، ولكن لا يمكن أن يتجاوز 3% ولو مرة 5%
وهذا طبعًا له هيئة صحية تحقق وتعاقب
ويستحق العقاب وما إلى آخره
أنه تعمد الإهمال
لكن تعال شوف الناحية الثانية
حق المنشأة الغير مجهزة
مثلًا اليوم فيه عيادات هي عيادات حق جلدية أو تجميل
وفيها طوارئ بحكم لهذا
صار حادث، وواحد شاف أقرب مستشفى له ودخل
هذه ما هي مهيئة أن تعامل مع واحد
عنده قطع في الشريان في الفخذ وتهشم في الجمجمة
بس هو عنده حل اثنين: يا يرفضه ويموت في الشارع
أو أنه يحاول
يا أنه يرفضه أو أنه يحاول
هذا الجراح يمكن جراح جراحة عامة
ماهو متخصص في الأنسجة والشراين والأوردة والشعيرات
ولا غرفة العمليات مجهزة لهذه الحالات، بس هو بيحاول
ولا الطاقم
بالضبط، مات المريض؛ يُحاسب هو
يبدأ تحقيق
يحسب خطأ طبي، ويحاسب
للأسف، وهنا مشكلة إدارية
أن الطبيب في هذه الحالة يتمرمط شوية
الين يثبت أنه سوّى اللي عليه
وهذا أنا أشوفه خطأ كبير
الإدارة والقيادة تتطلب أن ننظر للمنظور
بشكل أوسع، بشكل أكثر شمولية
هو ما أهمل وما تعمد الخطأ، لو أعاقبه أنا اليوم
هنا بتصير أخطاء طبية ثانية وبيحاولوا يخبوها
بيحاول الممارس الصحي يخبيها ما تظل، لأن أنا بتحاسب على شيء
ثانيًا، أنت بتخليه لو يكون فيه حالات مثل كذا
يقول لك مالي علاقة، خليه يموت مالي علاقة، لا
مع أن من الممكن أن يكون فيه فرصة بسيطة لإنقاذه
بالضبط، هذا اليوم اللي أنت تحتاجه
بالعكس، أول من يحميه أنا
احنا عندنا تعلمناها زمان، مدرستين إدارية
في التعامل مع أخطاء الموظف وتنطبق هنا
فيه المدرسة البريطانية وفي المدرسة الإسبانية
البريطانية اللي تعتمد موظف أخطأ في نظام يعاقبه وانتهى الموضوع
المدرسة الإسبانية لا، موظف أخطأ
تعال نشوف أيش سبب الخطأ، كيف صار؟ سببه الجذري
وكيف نعالجه بحيث ما يتكرر
ولا يعاقب الموظف إلا في حال ثبوت الإهمال
هذا اللي تحتاجه، هذا اللي لازم تزرعه في المنشأة
اليوم احنا عندنا في السعودية
أنا لما كنت في مكتب تحقيق الرؤية
هذه كانت من الجزء اللي الوزارة شافتها واشتغلت عليها وسوتها
اليوم، صار عندنا من نماذج الرعاية، نماذج الحرجة
وحطوا فيها ثلاثة أشياء
اللي هي الجلطات، وأمراض القلب الحادة والحوادث
حوادث سقوط، حادث سيارة أيًّ كان
صار فيه بالتنسيق مع الهلال الأحمر مع الإسعاف مع الخطط
صار فيه تنسيق كامل، لما تجي حالة مثل كذا فين تروح؟ فين تعالج؟
هذا من أيش؟ هذا من الشفافية اللي في البيانات
اللي خلت الناس تتكلم في المستشفيات
اللي خلت يصير فيه فعل ويعدل ويصلح
لكن لما احنا نقمع أو كذا؛ هذا بيكون خطير
تروح إلى الناحية الثالثة، مضاعفات بعد العملية هذا لا يمكن تمنعها
كل ما تملك أن تخفف منها، تحاول تقللها قدر الإمكان
تحتاج مكافحة عدوى أفضل، لو كان مثل التهاب في جرح
تحتاج فريق طبي أكبر، زيادة أعداد فريق مثلًا تمريض
بدل من 1-5 تخليها 1-4
تبدأ تلعب في الأشياء هذه لتحسين الحالة
آخر شيء عندنا اللي هي المضاعفات حق المرض
أو التدهور الحالة المرضية
واحد جاء كورونا، دخل المستشفى على رجله، يكح ويكح
عنده كورونا، يدخل المستشفى تنويم
نشوف العمر، عنده مرض سكر، عنده بلاوي الدنيا من الأمراض المزمنة
هذه مبدئيًّا في الطب يسموها «حالات ميؤوس منها»
يعني هذه حالة بتموت، نهايتها معروفة، بس لنحاول
فيه حالات نجت، بس فيه حالات لا
كورونا ومن كورونا أنا أعطيته المنشطات والأشياء اللي يحتاجها
لإيقاف المناعة من أنها تقتله والأشياء هذه كلها
بس تدهورت الحالة وانخفض ضغط الدم وتوفى
هنا محسوب خطأ طبي
متى ينفى الخطأ الطبي؟ حتى تشوف العناوين الصحفية
تقول لك خطأ طبي في مدري إيه
هل احنا صحفيًّا تابعنا نتيجة التحقيق حق الخطأ الطبي؟
لأنه هو يروح ويشوف هل الحكم كان صح أم غلط إلى آخره
فهذا طبعًا ماله علاقة فيها
فهذا معنى أخطاء طبية
طيب على النقطة اللي قبلها ودي افتح باب
العدوى، فيه أمراض معدية وفيه أمراض غير معدية
وشلون العدوى؟ أيش اللي يخلي مرض يعدي ومرض ما يعدي؟
الأمراض المعدية هي تعدي لأنها معدية. لأن اللي يسببها...
أيش طبيعتها اللي تخليها معدية؟
الكائنات اللي بتدخل، تكون أحياء دقيقة دخلت أجسامنا
عن طريق ناقل معين، بعوضة، شوكة
التهاب عملية برضه يكون بسببها
هذا يكون فيه مرض معدي جاني من حيوان، جاني من نبات
مرض معدي دخل سبب لي مشكلة في الأنسجة حقتي
أيًّ كان مكان العدوى
الأمراض الغير معدية، لا
مو شرط أن يكون مسببها من الأحياء الدقيقة أو من الميكروبات
لا ممكن أسبابها ثانية، ممكن واحد جاء له سرطان
ممكن واحد جاء له مرض مناعي ثاني
ممكن واحد حساسية في العين
وممكن عنده أصلًا مشكلة خلقية أو عيب خلقي في الأنف
في الجيوب الأنفية، وهذه من المشاكل اللي كنا نتكلم عليها
لما تدّعي في الحجامة أنها تعالج الجيوب الأنفية
هي بتعالج لك العيب الخلقي، وللا بتعالج لك الحساسية
وللا بتعالج لك الالتهاب البكتيري
وللا بتعالج لك التهاب الأنف المزمن، بتعالج لك أيش؟!
فهذه الأمراض وهذه الأمراض
هل ممكن نوصل أن نعيش في عالم ما فيه أمراض معدية؟
قدرت البشرية أن تقضي تمامًا على بعض الأمراض المعدية مثل الجداري
إيه، بس أنت لازم تعرف أن هذه الكائنات جدًّا ذكية
هي مو قاعدة تستناك تقتلها وتتفرج
هي كمان بتتطور
كيف قدرنا نقضي قضاء تام على الجدري؟
أنت لازم تتكلم عن قدرة كل كائن
قدرته على الانتشار، قدرته على التحول
الحمض النووي حقه، أيش هو نوعه، يفرق
لأن مثلًا الـ «آر إن إيه» للفيروسات وهذا
الحمض النووي حق «آر إن إيه» تحورها أكثر بكثير
وأسرع من الـ«دي إن إيه»
ظروف كثيرة، البيئة العامة، الهجين العام الموجودة في مجتمع معين
ليش اليوم فيه أمراض كثيرة ماهي عندنا ولا نسمع فيها
بس مستوطنة في بعض الأماكن في إفريقيا
الهجينة العامة، الصحة العامة، برامج التطعيمات، برامج الوقاية
نعم، فيه أمراض تم القضاء عليها في العالم كله
معاد فيه حالات
بس باقي الأمراض الثانية، ما أبغى أقامر على قولهم في المعلومة
ولكن أعتقد أنه ما نقدر
ما نقدر؟
ما نقدر، لأن الكائنات هذه جدًّا ذكية، وسلوكنا يؤكد أن ما بنقدر
أنت اليوم يطلع لك فيروس مثل كورونا
كم واحد يقول لك ما بطّعم
واحد مثل إنفلونزا لا ما بطّعم، التطعيم يحطوا لي فيه شريحة
تتكلم أنت على الحمى الشوكية
كل الأمراض اللي فتكت؛ شوف ردود فعلًا الناس تجاه الموضوع
وهو الناس لو تفهم أيش يعني لقاح
لو تفهم أيش مناعة، لو تفهم أيش عدوى
مابتوصل لذي المرحلة، الوعي عندنا...
أيش يعني عدوى؟ أيش يعني مناعة؟
فيه مساحة؟
كل المساحة
شوف المناعة هي جهاز من أجهزة الجسم
يتكون من عشرات الأنواع من الخلايا
كل نوع فيه وظائف مشتركة ووظائف مختلفة
بروتينات بعضها يتفاعل لحاله، بعضها تفاعل بمشاركة مع شيء ثاني
تفرز بشكل عام، شيء من نخاع العظم
شيء من الكبد، شيء من الأنسجة، شيء من الغدد
هذا المناعة هي شبكة كاملة، تدير منظومة كاملة
هدفها حماية الجسم من الأمراض المعدية
هدفها ما ينتج داخل جسمنا خلايا مؤذية مثل الخلايا السرطانية وغيرها
ومن أهم خصائصها أنها تقدر تفرق ما بين حقي ومو حقي
أيش قصدك؟
الخلية أو الشيء اللي يخصني، هذا تبع جسمي وهذا مو تبع جسمي
وتفرّق، اللي مو تبع جسمي، أسوي ضده ردة فعل وللا ما أسوي؟
هذا يسمونه «التسامح المناعي»
هذا من أهم الأشياء اللي يقوم بها جهاز المناعة
فهذا بشكل عام المناعة
يعني جهاز المناعة هو
هو مجموعة من الخلايا والبروتينات اللي تعمل مع بعض
للأهداف اللي قلت لك عليها
أيش رأيك، أشبك لك العدوى في المناعة
أعطيك حالة مثلًا عدوى كيف تصير
وأيش تسوي المناعة، عشان تكون أوضح؟
إيه
شوكة جاتك أو إبرة أو أي حاجة فيها فيروسات، انغزرت فيها
أول طبقة من طبقات الحماية في الجسم هي الجلد والأغشية المخاطية
أنت بالشوكة هذه أو بالشيء هذا
أنت تجاوزت الخط الدفاع الأول
دخلنا في الأنسجة، الأنسجة فيها نوع من أنواع الخلايا
أيش بيسوي؟ بيجي يقرّب منها، هذا مو تبعي
لأنه يعرف إذا هذا حقي أو مو حقي
لا، هذا مو حقي، أيش يسوي؟ يبلعه
لما يبلعه أيش بيصير؟ بيسوي شغلتين
الشغلة الأولى، بيطلّع مواد
يسمونها «cytokines & chemokines»
المواد هذه، أيش وظيفتها؟
شفت اللاسلكي؟ هذا مثل اللاسلكي اللي يبلّغ خلايا المناعة
يا جماعة الفزعة، عندي هنا جسم غريب مو تبعنا، أحتاج فزعتكم
فتبدأ خلايا المناعة تتجمع حول المنطقة اللي فيها هذه
كيف تتجمع؟ طبعًا المواد هذه اللي طلعت لي اللي حق اللاسلكي
تعطي إشارات للشعيرات الدموية أنها تتوسع شوية
فتسمح لبعض الخلايا حق المناعة أنها تمر
وتدخل في النسيج في منطقة العدوى
دخلت هذه الخلايا، وهذا الشيء مرة مهم
دخلت هذه الخلايا، طبعًا الدخول والتجمع هذا
بيعطيك في المنطقة هذه شوية انتفاخ وحرارة موضعية
هذه تشوفها في أي مكان
هذه أيش هي؟ هذا احنا نسميها التهاب
الانتفاخ مع الحرارة نسميها التهاب
الالتهاب هذا شيء احنا نصنعه وأيش هدفه
احنا نصنعه للحماية، الالتهاب المتحكم فيه هذا يحمينا
أيش يسوي؟
أول شيء أي ميكروب يحتاج لدرجة حرارة معينة عشان يتكاثر
غالبًا تكون درجة حرارة جسم الإنسان
لما نرفع الحرارة عليه، أنا ما أعطيه درجة الحرارة الملائمة أن ينقسم فيها
والثانية كمية السوائل اللي زادت هذه
لو يفرز هذا الميكروب أي سم من السموم؛ بخففه
فإتلاف الأنسجة يكون أبطأ. هذه أول خطوة
الخطوة الثانية، هي الآن بلعت صح؟ تبدأ تكسره جوتها
لما تكسره تبدأ تطلع على سطحها المكونات الأساسية لهذا الميكروب
من ضمن الخلايا اللي ناديناها باللاسلكي وجات
واحدة من الخلايا سموها «T lymphocyte helper»
هذه طبعًا أنا أسميها في المناعة المايسترو
اللي هي تنظم لك كل شيء
هذه الخلية جات، أخذت من اللي طالع على السطح هذا المكونات هذه
وراحت على الجهاز الليمفاوي لنوع خلايا ثانية
قلت لها تفضلي جبت لك من الحدود حقنا
أعطتها الخلايا هذه
الخلايا هذه أيش بدت تسوي؟ بدأت بنفسها
تخصصت أو انقسمت وصارت خليتين مختلفة
أيش صارت؟
الخلية أولى سوتها أرشيف
أرشفت المعلومات حق الميكروب هذا اللي دخل
الخلية الثانية اشتغلت على الكود الموجود في الشيء اللي أنا أخذته
وطلعت له أجسام مضادة متخصصة
نحن نفترض أن حالة ذي الميكروب ذا أول مرة يدخل جسم الإنسان
فهذه العملية كاملة بتمشي
بتطلع الأجسام المضادة وتروح لموقع العدوى
وتعمل تحييد للميكروب اللي موجود
التحييد يعني إيه؟ الأجسام المضادة ما تقتل
يعني تكلبش، بحيث أن الميكروب ما يمسك في الأنسجة ويتلفها
هو ما يقدر يحارب، خلاص متكلبش
فتبدأ خلايا المناعة تقضي عليه
هذه العملية تاخذ تقريبًا للعدوى بأول مرة
سبعة أيام أو عشر أيام حسب حاجتين أساسية
حسب الكفاءة المناعية حق الشخص
وكمية العدوة اللي دخلت، فتاخذ من سبع إلى عشر أيام
اللي هي الفترة اللي الواحد أول ما يجي له مرض
تجي له أعراض، وبعد كذا تبدأ تدريجيًّا بعد أربع أو خمس أيام
تبدأ تخف الين تختفي، لأن بدت الأجسام المضادة تطلع ضد الخلايا
لأنك وأنت تحارب وتحاول تسوي الكلام ذا كل الوقت
البكتيريا وللا الفيروس مو قاعد يستناك
قاعد يحارب ويطلع سموم ويطلع الأشياء هذه كلها
وبكذا برضه الإنفلونزا نفس الكلام؟
هو الإنفلونزا نفس الكلام نعم، بس أنا أقول لك
أن الوضع في الإنفلونزا وضعها يختلف شوية، ليش؟
أجيك حبة حبة
وهذه نقطة مهمة، هذا قلناه احنا في أول مرة
طيب لو جاني بعد سنة، سنتين، ثلاثة؛ نفس الحاجة
كم ياخذ؟
بياخذ يومين فقط، ليش؟
متدرب
فاكر الخلايا حق الأرشيف اللي عندي؟
أول ما يدخل، خلاص أنا عارفك ولا أحتاج أحد يشرح لي عنك
مباشرة نطلع لك أجسام مضادة خلال 24 ساعة يبدأ هو ينتهي
وأحيانًا حتى ما تحس بالأعراض حقته
واو!
لذا هذا يقودنا إلى نقطة، ليش التطعيم؟
حبيت
التطعيم نعيد نفس السيناريو حق العدوى
مادة جزء من الفيروس أو من البكتيريا
أو من الشيء اللي أنا بطّعم ضده، أنا بحقنك فيه
بالنسبة للمناعة، هي ما تعرف هل هذا فيروس وللا بكتيريا
تعرف حقي وللا مو حقي، مثل ما قلنا
هذا مو حقي يلا نبدأ
طبعًا أنت ما قد تطعمت، ما قد جاك عدوى بالمرض ذا
تعال نمسك النوع هذا، وبنمشي بنفس الطريقة
نسجله في الأرشيف ونطلع له أجسام مضادة
بس الفرق هنا في التطعيم؛ أن هذا ما بيسبب لي مرض
ليش؟
لأنه جزء من الفيروس أو فيروس مقتول أو فيروس مضعف
ما بيسبب لي مرض، فهو ما راح يتكاثر، ما بيسوي الأشياء ذي كلها
الفيروس اللي أنا اللي حاطه وأنا اللي متحكم فيه، أنا صانعه
فأنا عارف أيش بحقن فيه، فأنا ما أحقن لك بشيء اللي بيمرضك
أنا بحقنك بشيء يحفّز مناعتك فقط
النقطة وهذه مهمة، لما أقول لك أجسام مضادة متخصصة
أيش يعني؟ يعني هي فقط مخصصة ما تقتل غير الفيروس هذا
نفس حكاية القفل والمفتاح
أنت عندك الانفلوانزا لها قفل، أنا بطلّع مفتاح فقط لهذا
لو جاني قفل كورونا ما بيفتح، لأن ماله علاقة
تحتاج أنك تؤسس لكورونا، لأنه مختلف تمامًا جذريًّا عنه وهكذا
فأنت اليوم لما يرجع لي، أنا خلاص أخذت التطعيم
الجسم سوّى ردة الفعل للمناعة وسجّل في الأرشيف وكل حاجة
على جزء من الفيروس اللي أصلًا الأجسام المضادة تمسك فيها
بس أنا ما حسيت فيه يوم حطيته لي
أنت ما حسيت، ما عندك أعراض
ما حسيت بالجهاز المناعي
لا، أنت بتحس ممكن شوية حرارة
شفت لما يجيك حرارة وانتفاخ؟ هو ذا خلاص ما نبغى أكثر من كذا
ما في أعراض مرض، لأن هذا اللي جاك مو مرض أصلًا
والجهاز المناعي على الجسم كله خلاص يعمّمه
طبعًا، هو الخلايا بالملايين
والأجسام المضادة موجودة في كل الجسم تقعد
كلها عند الأرشيف وفي الجديد
وموجودة، ولو جاء جديد؛ بيطلع كميات زيادة وهكذا
عشان كذا اللي يقول لك، تعال أنت تبي تتخلص من سموم التطعيم
نسوي لك حجامة ونطلع لك السموم
هذا الشيء يخلي الواحد يضحك
لما تكون فاهم أنت أيش قاعد يصير
أنت فهمت المناعة دحين كيف شغّالة؟
واحد يقول لك خذ حلبة أنت تقوي المناعة
أيش تقوي في المناعة؟
أنا بقوي اللي أنت تقوله، كفاءة المناعة، مو تقول قبل شوي
أنا قلت لك من فين تصدر، من كبد ومن غدد ومن نخاع عظم
الحلبة هذه بتقوي أيش؟
بتطلع لي المناعة من فين؟
الفعل حقها على فين؟
غير منطقي لما تقولها، الكلام غير منطقي
عشان كذا فيه أشياء مضحكة لما تكون فاهم أيش الفكرة
سؤالك على الإنفلونزا، الإنفلونزا من الفيروسات الذكية
اللي تقريبًا كل سنة يغيّر القفل حقه، يغيّر القلب
شفت القفل ذا، يغيّر القلب كل سنة
فتحتاج أن تعدل المفتاح عشان يركب عليه
واحنا كيف نعرف أنه تعدل هذه السنة؟
هو تشغيلة كل سنة
أنت كل سنة بتنزل لك في الصحة مثلًا عندنا في السعودية
أو في «إم إن سي سي» في العالم جرعة السنة
إيه، بس كيف يعرفوا أن هذا القفل الجديد؟
أيش اللي كيف يعرفوا! هو الفيروس بالفعل موجود
هو يتغير مرة واحدة في السنة وللا يتغير أكثر من مرة في السنة؟
لا، التغيير الجذري اللي يخليه يتطلب
تعمل قفل على التطعيم هو مرة في السنة تقريبًا، ليش؟
ما بندخل مرة في التفاصيل
لا عادي، الحين هو يتغير مرة واحدة في السنة
إيه، هذا كإنفلونزا
أنا بعطيك تطعيم قبل لا يجيك، صح؟
لا، مو الحين الفيروس موجود وسلوكه موجود
أنا بعطيك التطعيم، هي فيه حاجة اسمها ممكن التفاعل المتبادل
يعني بيغطي كامل الأشكال هذه لو صار فيها
أنا فاهم كيف سلوك الفيروس وكيف بيصير
بشكل عام
بس كيف أعرف النموذج هذه السنة؟
هي ما تجي بالمللي، اليوم بيطلع إصدار وبكرة بنبدأ نطعّم
لا، ماهي كذا
هي تبدأ تتحور من شكل إلى شكل
أنا عارف المسار حقها اللي ماشي
هل التطعيم حق السنة هذه هو نفسه حق السنة الماضية
بس أنت لازم تاخذ كل سنة؟ وللا يغيرونه كل سنة؟
لا، هذيك اللي أنت تتكلم عليه جرعات معززة
مثل اللي صارت لسه في الكبد الوبائي
لا، إذا يتغير، ودعي أعرف كيف يتغير
كيف يعرفوا أن الإنفلونزا هذه السنة، أن الفيروس هذا القلب حقه
وأن هذا المفتاح، مو أنت تغيّر القلب
شفت الماستر كي؟ لو تغيّر لكذا أو كذا أو كذا بيحاول يفتحه
طيب ليش ما تسوي لي ماستر كي لحياتي كلها؟
هذا اللي شغال عليه العلم الآن
مو على الآن، شغال عليه من خمسة عشر سنة
أنه يشيل الإنفلونزا؟
أن تطعيمه وحدة عالمية؛ الإنفلونزا ينقضي عليه
فممكن يصير العالم بلا إنفلونزا؟
نعم، ممكن
واو!
اللقاح العالمي شغالين عليه
هي المشكلة في الإنفلونزا، في اللقاح حقها
أن بروتيناته كثيرة التغيّر
أنت أيش تحتاج عشان تطلّع لقاح واحد؟
تحتاج شيء ثابت، يكون سطحي خارجي
أقدر أمسك فيه بالأجسام المضادة
لو كان مافي، ما بقدر أسوي
التحديات في صناعة اللقاح كثير
أنت اليوم تتكلم عن الإيدز، ليش ما سووا تطعيم إيدز؟
ما أدري
لأن أيش الهدف حق مرض الإيدز؟
شفت الخلية اللي قلت لك عليها المايسترو؟
هي الهدف حق فيروس الإيدز
هو يدخل جوتها، لما يدخل جوتها صار خفي
الجهاز المناعي مو شايفه أصلًا
والخلية المايسترو هذه ماهي شايفتها
هذه مشكلة الإيدز
نفس الشيء عندك الحمى الشوكية...
دقيقة، دامك فتحت الإيدز، هل عالجوه؟
لأنها كانت أزمة، أتذكر زمان
هو فيه علاج بس مو علاج يقضي عليه
هو علاج يعامله كمرض مزمن
ويقدر يتزوج ويقدر يعيش، طالما ماشي بالعلاج والمتابعة
إيه موجود
وممكن يجي يوم يقضوا عليه؟
شوف التطعيمات إلى الآن واصل لمرحلة 30% - 40%
مو كإنجاز كفاعلية
أنت تحتاج توصل فوق الـ 50%
50% وصلت شكرًا، فهذه اللي لسه شغالين عليها
ما أدري إذا أنا قطعت فكرة أو ما قطعت فكرة
احنا كنا نتكلم الظاهر على التحديات
أنا الفكرة الأساسية اللي عندي، ردًا على سؤالك
كيف هي الميكروبات الذكية
فأنا قاعد أعطيك أمثلة، التطعيمات اللي أخذناها كمثال
أيش قاعدة تسوي الكائنات؟
جيتك على الحمّى الشوكية، أيش قاعد يسوي؟
الحمّى الشوكية هو بكتيريا، مو فيروس
فيه ستة أنواع هي اللي تصيب بالحمى الشوكية الممرضة
التطعيم اللي عندنا اليوم في السعودية ضد أربعة أنواع فقط
وهذا اللي من زمان طالع وشغالين فيه
فيه نوع أصلًا ما عاد تقريبًا فيه حالات في العالم
وفيه حالات قليلة في إفريقيا
فما فيه اهتمام أني أسوي له دعم مالي
عارف أنت هذه الأمور برضها تنحسب
لكن في نوع اللي هو الغالبية في أمريكا
الغالبية في أوربا، الغالبية في نيوزلندا
هذا النوع ولا احنا عندنا تطعيم ضده
بس برّا فيه، وليش أخذ وقت النوع هذا؟
وشوف هنا، كل الأربعة أنواع الثانية
أنت بتاخذ السطح حقها، القشرة هذه اللي برّا
تاخذه مثل ما قلنا، تحطه في تطعيم
حط الأربعة أنواع مع بعض، حطها في تطعيم وسوي تطعيم وامشي
طيب ليش ما أخذنا الخامس معاهم هذا؟
السطح هذا حق الخامس يطابق جزء من خلايا الأعصاب حقتنا
فلو حطيته؛ الجسم بيشوفه تبعي ما بهاجمه
ولا بكوّن ضده مناعة ولا بينفع
البكتيريا، السطح الخارجي حق النوع هذا اللي هو «بكتيريا المجموعة ب»
هذا النوع يطابق شكله شكل أطراف الخلايا حق الأعصاب عندنا
فبالتالي لما يدخل وأحط أنا التطعيم
جهاز المناعة لما يجي يشوفه يقول لا، هذا تبعي ما بسوي مناعة ضده
هذا مو تبعي؛ بسوي ضد هذا
فما فيه فائدة أني استخدام الطريقة هذه
قعدنا سنوات الين اخترع التسلسل الجيني
وسووا حاجة مثل القرصنة العكسية اللي في التقنية
نفسها علم اللقاحات العكسي يسموها
أنا آخذ كل جزء من الجين، وأشوف هذا مسؤول عن إخراج أي بروتين
وأبدأ أسوّي ضد بروتينات مشتركة بين الأنواع هذه
غير اللي على السطح، واللي تطلع موجودة
وأقدر أسوي المناعة ضدها
فأخذ الوقت الطويل هذا كله عشان لحاله طلع في النهاية
هو الظاهر طلع في العالم 2014 و 2015، قبلها ما كان موجود
طيب وليش موجود في أوربا ونيوزلندا وأمريكا وماهو عندنا؟
هو مرض معدي من شخص لشخص
الله يستر علينا، إن شاء الله، ما يجينا مع الانفتاح والأشياء هذه كلها
لأن ما عندنا، وهذا مرض قاتل
مرض من شخص سليم تمامًا، مثله مثلك قاعد كذا
إلى شخص في العناية المركزة
مع دعم وتشغيل على الأجهزة لكل عضو من أعضاء الجسم في 24 ساعة
ليش ما يعدينا طيب؟
احنا نفترض أننا مطعمين من الأربعة أنواع، النوع الخامس
إيه، النوع الخامس احنا ما نطّعم منه
المفروض نطعم منه لو جاء التطعيم
وليش ما جاء وهو طالع من 2015؟
لعله فيه حسابات ثانية
بس ما قد فيه ناس تموت، ما هو معدي وللا؟
أنا ما أقدر أعطيك إحصائيات، لأن ماني مطّلع بصراحة
وليش قلت انفتاح هنا، ما فهمت
لا، انفتاح الطيران أقصد
معليش، الإنفلونزا بما أننا داخلين على موسم الشتاء
هو يكثر في موسم الشتاء لأن الناس تقعد في البيوت أكثر وللا أيش؟
إيه. هو موسم الشتاء كل الأمراض التنفسية مو الإنفلونزا
الزكام والإنفلونزا وكورونا، كلها تكثر في موسم الشتاء
لأن الناس تجلس في أماكن مغلقة
انخفاض درجة الحرارة نسبيًّا يخفض الكفاءة المناعية
طبعًا لما نكون في مكان مغلقة، القرب والكلام
هذه الأشياء اللي تخلي الانتقال، زائد الجفاف
الجو الجاف يساعد في انتقال الفيروس أكثر من الجو الرطب
طيب، أنك تاخذ التطعيم الموسمي، هذا أفضل شيء
فيه شيء ثاني تسويه؟
شوف أنت مناعتك بشكل عام
هي فيه كلمة تقال، ارفع المناعة
طبعًا رفع المناعة هي لفظة تقال للتسهيل وتبسيطها للناس
لكن ما في حاجة اسمها رفع المناعة
رفع المناعة هذه حالة مرضية خطيرة
هي فيه حاجة اسمها خلي مناعتك تقوم بعملها بكفاءة
عشان تقوم بعملها بكفاءة تحتاج أكل غذائي متوازن
والأهم من الأكل الغذائي المتوازن، نظام حياة يكون جيد
فيه حركة، فيه النوم الجيد، فيه الضغوطات النفسية أقل
والأكل المتوازن، ما في أكلة ترفع المناعة
أو تساعدك على أن تكون مناعة أفضل، ما في
ما في شيء مثل كذا نهائي
المناعة كبيرة جدًّا، ما تقدر تحصرها في كمون وكركم وليمون
هذا كلام فارغ، هذا كلام غير صحيح
طيب هل فيه دواء يرفع كفاءة المناعة؟
ما فيه، أنا شرحت لك الآن قد أيش المناعة كبيرة
فما فيه حاجة اسمها أرفع كفاءة المناعة
فيه أشياء مهمة، لو كانت ناقصة عندك ممكن تتأثر المناعة
مثل؟
فيتامين دال، نقصه يأثر
ليش السعوديين عندهم فيتامين دال ناقص؟
كل العالم
كل العالم؟
كل العالم، نمط الحياة حقنا صار ما في تعرض أصلًا لبرّا
كلنا شغالين في الداخل، من سيارتك لمكتبك، إيه كلنا كذا
وحتى الشمس اللي عندنا، هذه الشمس ما تتعرض لها
آخذ حبة ولا أتعرض للشمس
وبعدين فرق البشرة يفرق في امتصاص فيتامين دال
كلما البشرة صارت أفتح؛ كلما الافتصاص صار أفضل
هل تختلف المناعة بين الرجل والمرأة وللا هي واحدة؟
ما في قاعدة مثل كذا، هي على حسب حاجتها لمناعتها
ليش تضعف المناعة عند كبار السن؟
شفت اللاسلكي والتواصل وإنتاج الخلايا وهذا
قدرة الخلايا على عملها مثل أول، ما تكون مثل ماهي شابة
تاخذ وقت أطول
إيه، وبعدين فيه أشياء قد حتى إنتاجها يتوقف
ونمط حياتك هو اللي يساعد في أنها تكون أفضل حتى وأنت كبير؟
قابلية أن جسمك أصلًا يشيخ في وقت متأخر؛ هذه قابلية جينية
فكون أنها موجودة مو بس للمناعة، لأي شيء كان
القابلية الجينية هي اللي تخلي واحد
فيه ناس والله في الستينات مدمورين
وفيه ناس يعيشوا للتسعين بصحة وعافية جيدة
يعطيك الصحة والعافية
الله يعافيك
شكرًا
شكرا لكم، شكرًا لعادل باعطية في الإعداد
وخلف الكاميرات وهاب موسى
وفي التسجيل الصوتي عبدالعزيز المزي
والهندسة الصوتية محمد الحسن
والتحرير محمد نور شمت
والتلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الإجتماعي نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج أيمن الحمادي
وفي إدارة التحرير أسيل باعبدالله
هذا فنجان، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
نشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
أنا كان عندي سؤال، تقول «بلاسيبو»
أن أحيانًا الواحد يتخيل
طيب ما تقول أن الطب الشعبي يمكن يكون شغال بذا الشكل؟
أن أنا عندي إعتقاد أن هذا الشكل
وفيه اللي يجي هذا الشكل
هذا نصب
لا، طيب ليش الطب الحديث ما يستخدم «البلاسيبو» للعلاج؟
لأن فيه خداع، أخلاقيات المهنة لا تسمح أن أخدعك عشان أعالجك
حتى وأنا بعالجك ما أخدعك، هذا مهم
فهي هذه الفكرة، أني أخدعك وأضحك عليك
فيه سؤال في الخلف
أيوة تفضلي
أنت لما تقول أن الثوم ما يعالج
بس أنت قلت عادي أنهم يحطون عليه كريم
نفس الكريم هو نفسه كأنه الثوم
لا، أنا أقول لك حتى الكريم ما يعالج
حتى الكريم ما يعالج
أنت تقول أنها جلدية
إيه، جلدية بس هو ما يعالجه، فيه محاولات بالإبر
بس الكريم برضه ما يعالج
فيه واحد من الأصدقاء جاته جلطة
شفت أنت تشرح قبل شوي على الجلطة اللي على الطاير
بالضبط، هو صغير، كم عمره؟ يمكن أربعة وثلاثين
جلطة في الدماغ، بس حتى راح المستشفى
فيه واحد قاله ما في جلطة
بس واحد قال له كل أعراضك أنت جلطة
بس أنهم يوم فحصوا وكذا
هي تكون عدّت
عدت كذا، وصار يتكلم ببطء لمدة أسبوعين أو ثلاث أسابيع
وبعدين رجع طبيعي
ورجع طبيعي
هذا لو راح انكوى
كان بيروح، راح فيه واحد في المدينة، قال له تكوي...
شفت لو انكوى، أيش بيقول لك؟ الكوي عالجني
شفت الخطر فين، ولو ما راح...
بس تراه راح المستشفى وقالوا له...
ما فيه شيء
قالوا له خذ الظاهر «إسبرين»
«إسبرين» «وارفرين»
هي هذه الفكرة، أنت بدون شيء هو بيرجع طبيعي
وفيه واحد ثاني كنت أشرح له
قال والله شكلها من التطعيمات
لأنها كثرة الحالات اللي مثل كذا
لا، ما فيه
ليش يجيه جلطة وهو صغير في السن؟
عادي يا أخي، تجي له جلطة وعنده قابلية
هو يدخن؟
لا ما يدخن
هو سمين؟
لا نحيف والله، نحيف جدًّا
تاريخ العائلة هذا أهم شيء
لا
ما أحد في أهله قد جاء له جلطة؟
حاس هذه من كيسك، حاسها ماهي معلومة تعرفها
لا والله، كنا نتناقش، فهو لما وصل لكورونا
كان يقول أن ما في شيء إلا يمكن أنه من التطعيم
يمكن ما كانوا يدرون، ما كانت تدري الشركة
ما له علاقة، ودحين أشرح لك تطعيمه أيش يسوي؟
أنا شرحت لك التطعيم وكيف تطلع أجسام مضادة
كيف ممكن التطعيم يكون غلط؟
يكون أول شيء مو آمن
وهذه أول مرحلة في التجارب العلمية أنه ما يكون آمن
أيش يكون مو بآمن؟
تطلع أعراض، يكون أعطيتك تطعيم
طلّع لي أعراض غير اللي أنا متوقعها علميًّا
واللي أنا طلعتها في المختبر وفي حيوانات التجارب
طلع لي شيء مختلف
طيب هم يقولون يمكن وحدة من مشاكلهم
أنهم بسرعة سووا التجارب، فاحنا كنا تجارب
هي حاجتين، احنا ما كنا تجارب
هي عدّت مراحل التجارب بالعدد الكافي
لكن احنا كنا دليل أقوى ومساعدة أكبر
لأن أنت لو ما عندك كورونا، تبغى تطلّع تطعيم
لا يمكن تصل إلى العدد اللي تطعموا في العالم ذا، لكن هذه ساعدت
هل يمكن أن الأعراض تطلع بعد عشر سنين؟
مين يقول؟
ما أدري، هل هو ممكن؟ هل هو وارد؟
نصف الحياة حق أشياء كثيرة في جسم الإنسان
خلال شهر، شهرين، ثلاثة؛ تتجدد
ولو فيه حاجة بتطلع ما بتطلع لك بعد عشرين سنة
وبعدين يا عمي خليها تطلع بعد عشرين سنة وتجيب السرطان
ولا أموت دحين بكورونا، خليها تجيني بعد عشرين سنة
وخصوص أنها تقنية جديدة برضه، صح؟
أنها تغيّر الحمض النووي، تلعب عليه
هذا الكلام من جديد، نرجع لأصل العلوم رابعة ابتدائي
يعرفوا أن الكلام ذا ما يصير
أيش يعني غيّر الحمض النووي؟
يعني هو يلعب على الـ«آر إن إيه» صح؟
لا، مو صحيح
قصدك اللقاح يشتغل على الـ«آر إن إيه» حق المرض، مو على أجسامنا
ما يغيّر الحمض النووي حقنا؟
إيه
لا، هو عبارة عن «ماسنجر آر إن إيه»
أيش يعني «ماسنجر آي إن إيه»؟
الحين أنا أقولك، ليش اختصر جزء كبير من عمل المعمل
أول أنت عشان تسوي اللقاح تاخذ البروتينات هذه
تحطها في واحد من الفيروسات المقتولة
عشان بس ردة فعل المناعة تكون أقوى
وتحطها في بيض وتخليه ينتج وتخليه يطلع
وليلة طويلة ومواد حافظة
هذه المرة ما سووا البيض ولا البطيخ
ولا أي شيء. دحين يا حبيبي هي التقنية
أنا أحقنك بـ«ماسنجر آر إن إيه»
و«ماسنجر آر إن إيه» بيدخل داخل الجسم وبعدين بيدخل جوّة الخلية
بيدخل النواة حق الخلية
بيخلي النواة حق الخلية
أي خلية؟
أي خلية، يخلي النواة حق الخلية أيش تسوي؟
يخليها تصنع له بروتين
البروتين هذا يشبه البروتين اللي على سطح كورونا
صار جسمي هو اللي أنتج البروتين بدل ما أحقنه في بيض
وفي معمل واستخراجه وأسوي الليلة ذي كلها
جسمي أنتجه، لما جسمي أنتجه؛ جات المناعة شافت، هذا مو تبعي
حتى لو أن جسمي أنتجه، هذا مو تبعي
يلا سوِّ ردة فعل المناعة، وأسوي مناعة ضده
انتهى الموضوع
والخلايا اللي بتصنعه بتموت و بتحيي غيرها
طيب معليش، الحين لما يجيك مثلًا ثعبان
ليش الجسم ما يتفاعل معه ويشيله
وليش أموت من السم حقه؟
هذا كان السؤال نفسه، لو شلل الأطفال جاء
ليش الجسم ما يتفاعل معاه ويقضي على الفيروس؟
ولو الحمى الشوكية جات، ليش الجسم ما يتفاعل معاه ويقضي؟
فيه قدرة مناعية معينة للجسم، هذه الكائنات أقوى
السم هذا
فالسم كميته أقوى
تحتاج مضاد سم له، السم كميته ما تتحملها المناعة
السرطان اليوم، نحن نقول الخلايا المناعية هي تعالج السرطان
أو تقضي على خلايا السرطان
طيب اليوم ليش ناس بيجي لهم سرطان أجل؟
قدرة المناعة ما تحتمل أو تكون أضعف من قوة التكاثر حقها
عشان كذا قلع لنا العلاجات حق الخلايا التائية والأشياء ذي كلها
اللي بتعالج واللي إلى الآن بيسووها لعلاج السرطانات والأشياء هذه كلها